harper now the science and technology
committee undertook an inquiry
into this new funding agency and we
issued a report on the 12th of february
the bill to bring into existence what
will be known as
arya the advanced research and invention
agency
backed by 800 million pounds of
taxpayers money
was published two weeks ago and is about
to begin its scrutiny
in both houses of parliament the prime
minister's
a previous chief advisor dominic
cummings is through his writings widely
thought to be the originator
of the arpa model as a proposal for the
uk
and indeed is known to be a supporter of
the the commitment
to increase the science budget now
he's no longer working for the
government he's free to speak and we're
very grateful for his attendance today
i'm also delighted to uh anticipate the
attendance
of the secretary of state for business
energy and industrial strategy the new
secretary of state
and his lead official on science policy
in what would be their first appearance
before this committee
now this is a session on science funding
the committee has also been inquiring
into the covid pandemic
and there are questions that we would
like to ask mr cummings
about the response to the pandemic he's
kindly agreed to give evidence
on that to the joint inquiry that we're
holding with the health and social care
select committee on lessons learned from
the pandemic and so that will allow us
to focus today's session
on science funding perhaps i can start
with a question to mr cummings what is
the problem to which aria is the
solution
um so i think there's a few
uh overall overall problems first of all
almost all science funders globally
operate in the same way they have pretty
much the same metrics like papers they
have pretty much the same kind of
horrific bureaucracy they waste huge
amounts of time
for the researchers in filling out all
of these forms and they get pretty much
the same results
secondly you have a few examples
historically of things that work on
completely different principles
and are super super productive but these
sort of entities
whether it's like the manhattan project
like the old lmb
uh like open 60s bletchley these sort of
things
are they tend to be
destroyed by bureaucracies pretty
quickly over time and the people
who run them tend to be tend to be
driven away it's turned out to be
extremely hard
for normal government systems to learn
from the most productive
enterprises you also have a situation
in which uh issues around science and
technology are increasingly important to
government we've obviously just seen
that in 2020 with
with kovid
and you also have this huge wall of
money from people like
from china and from america coming into
it so you have all of these different
pressures
on the system you have a white hole
which is not being configured to think
uh rationally about how to do science
and technology policy
britain can't solve all these problems
by itself and and and an agency can't
so i think obviously there's a whole
bunch of things that have to change in
the uk system
what arya can do though is to
is to look is to be decisively different
from all other funding entities
so i've got a chart done by a brilliant
scientist who wrote the textbook on
quantum computers a guy called michael
nielsen
i hope hopefully you can see this i'll
put it on my blog if it doesn't show up
very well
but he's on the committee's website as
well this is basically
where all funders globally are they're
in this little bubble here
but this is the actual design space for
how you could do science and technology
and the purpose of aria ought to be to
sample
in this broader design space to do
things
differently to learn from the things
that have been super productive in the
past
and that essentially means i guess in
very simple terms
it means extreme freedom
that's one of the great lessons of the
things that have been most successful
historically
that's what produced the internet and
the personal computing
revolution you need to so you did so you
need to strip out
all of the horrific whitewall
bureaucracy around procurement
state aid human resources
civil service pay scales uh all of these
sorts of things
and and huge center processes from the
treasury as well things like the
treasury business case process
which is horrific and causes huge delays
in science and technology there's logic
for it elsewhere in the system but as
applied to science and technology it's
very
it's very damaging so i think in a
nutshell where i would define the
purpose of arya is there's no point
creating it if it's just going to be
another one
another entity in that in that little
red thing right the purpose of it has to
be
to sample the wider space and to do
things very differently
and to do that with extreme freedom and
busting the bureaucracy that's
already there yeah we'll come and answer
more detailed questions about
each part of that and my colleagues
who've got some follow-up questions
um i think it's it's evident most people
accept that the the proposal to have a
uk
arpa now aria was yours
was it something that you proposed
to the prime minister was it part of a a
deal that you did with the prime
minister
to to join him so
i wouldn't say it's my idea i mean all
i'm doing is is doing
is suggest we're suggesting what a lot
of the
the best scientists and technology
people in the world have been suggesting
for decades actually that britain should
learn from some of these examples
including the 60s harper
so i wouldn't in any way this is not my
idea
essentially what happened in terms of
what you're talking about is the prime
minister came to speak to me
uh the sunday before he became prime
minister and said would i come into
downing street to try and help
um sort out the huge brexit nightmare
i said yes if
first of all you're deadly serious about
actually getting brexit done and
avoiding a second referendum
secondly double the science budget third
create some arpa-like entity and
fourth support me in trying to change
how whitehall works in the cabinet
office work
because it's a disaster certain and he
said
deal where did he say deal where were
you
when that was concluded uh in my living
room sunday before he became prime
minister just you and him or were there
others there
just just okay um
and now that you're not there
are you confident that the government
will stick to
the four elements of that one one has
clearly been uh
done already um i think that as
far as i can see from the budget that
the plan is to stick to the doubling of
this
of the science budget um
though there are some issues around that
i think that the fact that they brought
in the bill shows that the government
remains committed to doing it
i think the problem is is much less
likely to be does the government decide
not to bother trying to do an opera
the problem is this is this deeper
problem
that it's just you know there's a reason
why it's
on the one hand you think okay you've
got this model from the 1960s
it's so incredibly fruitful that a few
hundred million dollars
generates tens of trillions of dollars
in value with the internet the person
computer revolution
and all the other things that were spun
off our park obviously human
civilization will learn from that and
try and do the same thing right but in
fact it turns out that's not
not that's the opposite of of the truth
in fact what happens is
arpa itself the institution that did
that was itself very much changed in
1975 it became more bureaucratized
made it much harder to fund things like
the internet
so i think that's the real problem here
for for ferrari
it's not so much will the government
lose the will to do it
it's that the principles according to
which these sorts of things
are very successful are completely
hostile to
normal bureaucracies that's why they
don't normally happen
and therefore i think the bigger danger
is
that it sort of half happens that they
create something but it's basically no
different
and if you if if mps were going to
choose to do that then it would actually
be better
it might be not to bother doing it at
all the only point of doing it is
to is to make it decisively different
from what already exists otherwise
you're just adding to the chaos okay
we'll uh we'll come into some aspects of
that
but isn't there a paradox here about our
arya
it was in the queen's speech in october
2019
we're now in march 2021 nearly a year
and a half later
it hasn't even begun its passage through
parliament yet
yeah um you've just been very critical
of the the bureaucracy
um surrounding administration and
science
funding yet this institution seems to
have the gestation periods
of an elephant you were in office for 80
of this time you were after the prime
minister
the most powerful person in downing
street and some say
the country why were you not able to
make it happen during that time
so we made some progress in the second
half of 2019
on it but we were inevitably
fundamentally like everyone else in
politics we were uh swamped by the
brexit
uh um problem
as soon as the election was finished i
started work on this in
in january actually science funding was
the main thing that i worked
on in january immediately after the
election but of course then
um like everything else in in government
everything was
kind of swept away for a few months in
the first wave of covet but i think the
fact so you're obviously right
to point to the to to the delays but i
think
that show that having having had many
many dozens and dozens and dozens of
meetings on this
um it's connected to this to the problem
by uh
i mentioned in the previous sentence
doing something like this is so
contrary to how the normal system works
that it's very hard in whitehall
to push through something like this um
you have after over a year of discussing
it we suddenly had the treasury come
back
in um september october time
last year and say hang on a second hang
on we don't want to have primary
legislation at all
my god if we do this and we start
enshrining in legislation that some
entities
don't have to follow all of our
bureaucracy my god will
end everyone will suddenly want to have
this this wonderful freedom maybe we can
do this without having
the green speech in october 2019 why why
were you debating whether legislation
would be needed when it was included in
the queen's speech
because the treasury suddenly came back
and said we've come up with our own
different legal advice after a year of
everyone in whitehall debating it and we
actually think that we don't need a bill
after all and this is a completely
different way of doing it
uh so i think the whole episode shows
just how hard it is for whitehall to
to to deal with the concept of um
of of creating something with low
friction
um and removing things like the treasury
the the treasury business case final one
from me on this before i turn to
colleagues
in our reports we said that uh 800
million pounds
for a new science funding institution
is obviously very welcome as long as
that is not taken from
raiding very important existing science
budgets and
projects was part of your your deal with
the prime minister
that this should be additional or did
you
anticipate that this would come out of
other research programs including
medical research that has served us so
well during this pandemic
it was always very very explicit and
clear throughout my time in government
that this would be
additional money we made those
commitments to the royal society
to all the different funding councils to
everybody else this uh
this should all be part of the the
should be funded with new money from the
dublin that was always the original plan
that was the plan throughout my time in
government
um hopefully that hasn't changed if it
if it has then it shouldn't have done
and so you wouldn't expect that the
budgets for ukri for example
should be falling given this certainly
not so when i left
the ukri budget was uh was pencilled in
spending review to
get very generous increases over coming
years
as it should do thank you very much i'll
turn to my colleagues starting with
graham stream
morning dominic and thanks for coming to
the
uh committee are you
pleased with the detail uh in the bill
that will set up
uh this organization because when i
read it it looked as though the
bureaucrats who
you say destroy initiative and
innovation in the science world
had got their grubby myths on it because
at any time
the government can take control of the
organization if you look at
schedule one uh in in the bill
there are all sorts of other controls in
in section
uh two of the bill why are you
um pleased with it or disappointed with
it
there are too many restrictions
certainly in my model of it
um you wouldn't have ministers anywhere
near making decisions about how it
spends
money i think that will be a disaster
in my model it would be extremely it
would be extremely simple
you you would have you would find a
director
you'd have probably maximum four
trustees
so that they are actually real trustees
and they have real control not one of
these normal
government things with like 20 people on
a board so that no one's actually
exercising serious responsibility for it
um and you would cut it loose of the
of of the rest of the system um
so no i'm not confident about about uh
how how it will work out um there's
certainly very strong so
there's a mix as you would expect on the
one hand there's a lot of people who
under
know the history of things like arpa and
bell labs
um and the old lmb and whatnot who know
the value of this kind of model
and say obviously britain should do this
and there are a lot of brilliant
officials
who think it's a wonderful idea and
they've worked extremely hard to do it
but it's also crucial to remember that
the basic principle of extreme freedom
is completely hostile it's completely
the opposite of how all normal science
funding works
and how all normal whitehall works
so i think umps have to be have to be um
extremely vigilant in particular i think
vigilant about
um look
i think there's a tendency to think of
the science science funding system like
there's people running the system but
that's not the reality the reality is
the system runs the people
there's huge veto points everywhere so
everyone can block things everyone can
stop good things happening but almost
nobody can actually get anything done
um and this and and this chain of
bureaucracy runs all the way down from
the the people at the bottom of the
hierarchy in things like epsrc making
decisions about pure maths
through the hierarchy of epsrc through
ukri through bayes and then up to the
treasury
so you have these chains of business
cases and emails running up and down and
up and down this hierarchy
for month after month after month
driving everybody completely
insane but if you say
well let's just completely get rid of
that it may it makes no sense
then um you know some part of the system
say brilliant another part of the system
saying my god we can't possibly do that
right it seems to me that
as the trough bill is at the moment
there is less freedom
uh for scientific innovation and new
ideas than you would get in a university
department and there is more uh control
there is no overall mission statement
one of the strengths of uh
opera darpa when it was set up was
the there was an overall mission
statement which was to make the united
states of america
as safer place do you think it's a
mistake
not to have an overall mission statement
and just
incidentally in terms of the detailed
objectives in
sort of a bit two six a b and c in the
bill
it says look at the economy innovation
improving uh quality of life but there's
nothing about defense there is that a
mistake
so i think uh uh as you say if you if
you look at the euro if you look at the
original mission statement for the old
opera in in
1958 it was um to to to prevent
strategic surprise
in science and technology was something
like to prevent strategic surprise
in science and technology for the united
states um
my version of it for here would be as i
said to to
um to accelerate scientific discovery
far beyond what's currently normal
and to seek strategic advantage in
some fields of science and technology
for the united kingdom that's how i
would define it
and i would keep it broad and vague like
that
i would also point out that if you talk
to the old-timers who are actually
involved with arpa and saw the
transition to darpa in 1975
they think that that was a retrogame
retrograde step
and in fact darpa after 75 had to come
up with all kinds of bureaucratic
wheezes in order to try and fund things
like the internet in
in the future so i wouldn't give it a
specific defense focus i certainly
wouldn't try and import a bunch of
buzzwords like ai and quantum
and net zero and things like that i just
think it
it doesn't add anything i would stick to
[Music]
stick to a broad mission statement as
i've as i have described
sampling this border design space for
science and technology
and achieving strategic advantage for
britain in in some fields that's how
i would limit that's how i would define
it
but my final question i don't know if
you're familiar with the howard
hughes research um center just outside
washington dc
which has some of the best
scientists in the world looking at the
brain and how it functions trying to
make
breakthroughs it seems to me and i'd be
interested in your comments
that you are promoting something more
like
that howard hughes center on on on the
brain
rather than
a a uk darpa so
yes i am i am familiar with uh with that
i actually visited the janelia farm
uh where that institution is and
actually
i brought over a brilliant young british
neuroscientist
who was working there and he now works
in number 10 and he made some
critical contributions to how we uh how
the
british government dealt with um kofit
last year
um i i don't think that
what i'm proposing is not to have
something which is very which is
narrowly focused like that on one area
so i wouldn't just say aim at
neuroscience whatever i would leave
i would leave that those sort of
decisions to the the
institution i would to argue itself i
would leave it as a very broad science
and technology thing
not least because to begin with the the
people that are running it
um one of the crucial lessons for up in
the 60s and 70s was
giving people space for problem finding
not just sending them off saying solve
this problem straight away problem
finding is
is as important sometimes more important
than than solving
the problem so i think when you when we
create this thing
the people who are running it need space
and time to go out and talk to people
out on the ground
and figure out what are these uh ideas
by definition things like
creating the internet in the 60s are not
obvious they're not on the front pages
of the newspapers they're not all being
talked about in in scientific
conferences now they're not on the front
page of science and nature
by definition so it'll take time to go
and find these ideas and find these
uh often very odd people who who are
pursuing them
thank you very much indeed we'll go to
catherine fletcher now
thank you chair thanks um dominic for
offering to come and talk to us today
um what you're describing is almost like
a skunk works model if i put it in my
language which is
a bunch of incredibly bright people kind
of working in the same space and feeding
off each other
what do you actually want them to do you
keep saying go and sample but
are we sampling in highly theoretical
aspects
like i know i don't know aligning
quantum mechanics and special relativity
are you are you sampling in achieving
long-term goals like carbon attenuation
or are you just boiling the ocean with
800 million quid and hoping for the best
so i think i think it does definitely
have some similarities with
with the the famous skunk works uh in
terms of the kind of the culture of the
organization um
looking for very extreme talent and
having a very extreme antipathy for
bureaucracy are obviously two of the two
of the key elements of
of skunk works but i think it's not
i've sort of deliberately avoided giving
my you know views from i don't think
views from me or what sort of thing it
should be looking at i i
honestly have have any real value
um it should be going off to people
really
out on the far edges of of the
of the science world and talking to them
about what's
uh about what's um really what's really
valuable
now if you look back at what happened in
the early 60s it was um this guy lick
leider who said
actually computing could be done
completely differently i've got a vision
for how we can have
personal interactive dynamic computing
with everyone universally networked
worldwide and he wrote a famous memo
about the intergalactic
um communications network those things
are
they're not they they're hidden you know
they're not
it's not for me to come out and start
giving my my
my theories about about what they should
be you need to
find you need to find people who can go
off and talk
to these people out there and in
particular searching for young people
who
now struggle to get funding yes i was
going to come on to that so
and we i've been really personally
struck by
the amount of young bright researchers
that are frustrated with the bureaucracy
you know not least women who can't plan
a family because their funding
settlements only run for the next 12
months but
what i'm bothered about is the
fallibility of human beings in this
system
so if you've got like a tiny leadership
team of a director and four trustees
you're effectively looking for like five
sympathic balances
or hooks or boils or newtons
you know the how are you going to stop a
small number of people
getting the wall pulled over their eyes
by the tin foil hat brigade that come
along and say
if you give me 100 million quid i'm
gonna
you know stop aliens from being able to
read our minds how do you have in the
leadership the technical understanding
to not get the money spent badly
well so on your first point i think the
the youth thing is
is a critical problem uh i'll give you a
concrete example of that one of the most
influential physicists in britain in the
last 50 years is david deutch oxford who
wrote um
the famous papers around 1989 81 about
quantum computers which helps start the
whole
field going if you ask him he recently
went back to the people who actually
funded him and said you know what would
happen if i came to you
with my 1980 idea now and they all said
well there's obviously no way on earth
you'll never get funded now
so i think that sums up the problem
you're talking about that it's very hard
now for young people to get
funding for ideas which are far from the
normal you know now everyone babbles on
about quantum computers it's become a
buzzword
but it's how do you stop the tinfoil hat
brigade
pulling the wall over five people's eyes
with a lot of money
well you you've got to you've got to
pick the five people very carefully
but then those five so the open model is
that you have a very very flat
organizational structure you have a
director in charge of it
and then they have good taste in finding
people and there's no there's no
alternative to this fundamental problem
you have to have someone in charge who
has good
taste in scientific ideas
and in scientific researches that's how
all of these institutions work
it's how general groves operated the
manhattan project it's how
rowena found luke glider in the first
place it's how
uh liquidator found robert taylor it's
how robert taylor created xerox park in
the
1970s there is no alternative ever
discovered
on earth to having funders with great
taste
in ideas and people at the end i gently
point out that all the people that
you've just mentioned
are blokes and taste is one of those
subjective human things that we need to
be careful and worry about
when concentrating great power in a
small number of hands but
let me shift on to some of the evidence
that we've heard
from people previously it was all about
culture
and leadership and creating um
brains sparking off each other in
interdisciplinary areas
rather than giving an individual
maverick the funding to go and pro
you know produce that to what extent in
your
view of arya is that it where's that
collaboration
and where's that temporary nature that i
thought was very powerful evidence
so i think i think that i think this is
a very important point um
so i'll give a academia and universities
now one of the things that they're
terrible at and one of the things that
the current system is terrible at is
funding
teams to do certain things the system
now is
extremely focused on individual
researchers
writing papers it's terrible that
funding
teams where the output is not a paper
it's
software or it's a tool or something
like that so for example
uh um one example which which which
everyone in this community will be
familiar
familiar with is deep mind damascus
had to go to california and talk to
people like peter thiel to get cash
to get deep mind going because the
british funding system
just does not think naturally in in
in that way and that's exactly one of
the things i think that reo should be
should be able to do it should be able
to say ah okay
here is a lick lighter type person
they've got a vision of how they can
build this thing over the next 10 years
they need 50 million quid a year for say
10 years
right there you go knock yourselves out
that's exactly the sort of thing
that it should be doing but i don't
think it should be limited to that so
i think a crucial distinction is that
often is lost in this arpa darpa thing
is
now darpa is very much focused on what's
referred to as missions and moon shots
and things like that where you have
a specific goal and a specific deadline
so the
1960s apollo put a man on the moon by
the end of the decade
that's a great model and that can bring
fantastic
uh progress for civilization but it's
not the only way of doing things and
aria should not be limited to that
and i would point out that the liquid of
vision for
personal computing and interactive
computing in the internet
was not such a moon shot it was a much
more kind of ephemeral
thing and much more powerful for for it
being that
it actually drove decades of
of research and discovery and was so
rich that you still have people
now 50 years later in silicon valley
people like brett victor
setting up new labs saying people have
missed this idea from 50 years ago
so i think arya should have that kind of
freedom to do both
to do both things it should be able to
find the lick lighters but it should
also be able to fund
specific moonshots if it wants to i'm
i'm with you i mean you know i could
spend ages debating scientific murder
with you i'm
very conscious that we've got a public
audience who are
funding this ultimately so final
question chair uh
we'll come back uh catherine if we may
we need to go to to dawn but we'll
i'll bring you in a bit later um dawn
thank you very much chair and thank you
dominic for coming into the committee
and dominic you spoke earlier about
finding scientists from america
bringing them over to work in number 10
i know you
would have thought about this quite
intently who do you think should be in
charge of and who do you think should
lead
arya and why so i think the the
the sort of person um i'll give you
three i'll give you
three people just as the sort of people
who who i um
i i would think of um there's a guy
called michael nielsen
uh he wrote the the textbook on quantum
computers
i think it's one of the top 10 cited
physics books ever or something
but he's also spent the last 10 years
really thinking living in san francisco
really thinking about how
science itself works he wrote a
brilliant book called reinventing
discovery
he would be a perfect person because
he's actually done brilliant science he
knows these people but he's also
unusually for scientists actually
studied the process in the history of
funding and written a book about
it and he's seen this kind of
intersection in the worlds of
science technology venture capital um
project management et cetera in in
in palo alto and places so someone like
that i think would be a great example
um steve sue the physicist uh who's also
worked in
genomics and other things and also from
the startup world again
he's got a mix of different backgrounds
in britain
there's a there's a brilliant
mathematician who won the fields medal
called tim gowers
um uh tim i think would be
has exactly the right kind of mindset
and character
uh and would be a wonderful person to
have either running this or to be
or to be chairman of it if
if if he wouldn't run it there's a
brilliant
physicist called kiara
who's one of david deutsche students
she's she's a classic example
of a young female scientist who's
struggling for funding now
um but has brilliant ideas uh
those are the sort of people that i
would need to be involved in
in this kind of entity i would say thank
you great thank you so obviously these
are the people that you know
and you talked about having scientists
on the edge
you know the wild cards and the misfits
the people that you really like so
um this is going to be your legacy
okay uh how will you stay involved
oh i mean i won't be involved i i
i'm not seeking to be involved um i
wouldn't want to be involved i shouldn't
be involved
why why shouldn't you be involved
well the only way in which i could add
any value to it would be if you picked
the wrong people
uh in the first place i mean if you pick
the right people then what what could i
possibly contribute to it
great so if you were offered a position
you wouldn't take it
no i know that there are some rumors
around about that sort of thing and
rumors that number 10 has asked me to do
it or whatever but that
but um i don't know if they are thinking
about that but if
if it was suggested i would certainly
say no
thank you and do you consider eugenics
to be a science and do you think it
needs more research
um i don't really know what you mean by
by eugenics there's obviously a huge
amount of work now going on
in genomics in understanding how the
genome
works and there's a huge amount of work
happening in genetic engineering and
technologies like crispr
which have both huge promise and also
huge potential disasters
i certainly think that one of britain's
great scientific advantages
is our leadership in this field in
genomics genetic engineering things like
that
it's proved that advantage has proved
extremely valuable in in covid
because i think we've been one of if not
possibly even the
leading scientific country in sequencing
um different variants of of covet
so i strongly think that that
fundamental science research should be
funded here
um thank you why uh why isn't aria
um a division of uk ri
did you not see that in your kind of
brainchild idea when you was putting it
all together there will be
even if it's a sub um remote arm of ukri
no i think it definitely should not be
part of ukri and
um and ottoline laser the director of
ukri
agrees with me um you know uh it's a
young organization it's done some
excellent things but it also
suffers from uh this very
uh extreme bureaucracy problem
um we i had to spend a lot of time last
spring
for example dealing with blockages in
the funding system to
uh therapeutics uh that were necessary
for
for uh for dealing with covet and there
were lots of blockages in the system
then it's one of the many reasons why we
why we chose to do the vaccine program
the way that we did so uh
i would i think if you're going to put
it inside ukri then don't do it at all
it would be my would be my with my
advice as i said before
the only justification for doing this is
if you do it
outside of the existing system and
outside of the existing processes
if you're going to just put it inside
ukri then all you're doing is adding to
the bureaucracy and
everyone will be far better off just to
give you kyra the money and not better
not bother creating it
um and i'd point and i just stressed
that ottolin
having been there agrees with this
okay thank you and uh my last question
um so you said in january this was your
main thing that you worked on the
science aria do you is that the reason
why you were given the 45 000 pound pay
rise
uh no so the the media reports about
about me getting a pay rise after covert
are wrong
it is true that i interfered with the
pay system regarding my own pay
but that was in summer 2019
when i arrived i was put on the normal
pay ban for my uh
for my position of 140 something
thousand
i said that i didn't want that and i
only wanted to be paid what i was paid
at vote leave i figured that i should be
paid the same for trying to sort out the
brexit mess as i've been paid for doing
vote leave so
i asked for a pay cut which is what
happened in
summer 2019. for some reason this has
appeared in the media as if i got
a pay rise after kovid but that didn't
happen when we were all rehired
in uh the day of the uh the day after
the election
then um i moved back onto the normal pay
grade for my
uh for my for my position wow
thank you for caring thank you very much
erin bell thank you for coming in today
uh um i agree with what you what you
were saying with graham
earlier about the risk about
bureaucracies it strikes me a lot of the
examples
you gave about how this has worked well
in the past manhattan project uh darfur
itself
they stemmed from an existential sense
of crisis whether the second world war
or the cold war
a couple of years ago the government
looked at the grand challenges of ai and
data
asian society clean growth future
mobility those are all challenges but i
don't think they ever felt a sense of
existential crisis
and we've just been through an
existential crisis which has seen huge
innovations particularly with
mrna vaccines yeah without the crisis
will aria really work
it's um that is a very
good question i mean you're right
historically these things do
tend to be created and particularly only
to be given
extreme freedom when uh when you do
face some kind of existential crisis um
i hope that the the
the disaster of um of last year
uh in a rational world it ought to make
the case
for arya just completely open and closed
remember in february march april last
year there was no
entity in the british state zero
entities
including the prime minister himself who
could make
rapid decisions on science funding
minus horrific eu procurement
state aid etc etc laws
no entity in the british state that
could operate
at scale and a place and that
was obviously disastrous and
it seems to me that one of the most
obvious lessons
of last year is that a we should go to
extreme lengths to try and
de-bureaucratize the normal system
but secondly you have to accept that
there's always going to be you know
certain sets of rules for for for
certain sorts of things
you need to have an emergency process
where
um an entity of the state can actually
move
speed and scale to do all sorts of
things buying a procurement or whatnot
but i think it also it also makes the
case for creating an
institution like arya um i think all
the other thing i mean an obvious thing
so i've deliberately tried to
not get into sort of my own ideas for
what sort of things we would find
but it seems to be obvious that one of
the things that should be funded now
is
is a combination of mass distributed
testing at home
mass distributed genetic sequencing
mrn mrna vaccines and the supply chains
to scale them up
if you look at the guy who's recently
ran the u.s
biosecurity program so he's responsible
for trying to deal with
is north korea trying to develop some
small blocks and
stuff like that sure he said recently
there's actually a road map if you talk
to the top scientists in the world
people like george church there's a road
map for how
over the next five ten years you could
actually build this infrastructure to
deal with pandemics
so that we don't have the kind of
disaster that we saw last year
that's the sort of thing that i think
should be the impetus for for creating
an entity like this does that not make a
case for potentially making the
department of health or the nhs itself
the client for arya in the same way that
the department of defense was for darpa
no i don't think so i think i think that
there is certainly a case for
the department for health i think i
think all the all government departments
both have to take science and technology
far more seriously than they have them
so far and have better funding for it in
their normal provision
and they should also all have a small
little pot maybe five percent of the
budget
that goes to funding people who are
thinking very long term
and uh and are on the edge so i think
that there's an argument for lots of the
for
department for health for example um
having an entity the
the the that could do that
obviously last year we saw the
department for health
um had just absolutely total disaster in
terms of buying
how it buys how it procures how it deals
with science and technology um
it's why we had to take the vaccine
process out of the department for health
um but i don't think that that means i
don't think the right and
i don't think that leads you to the
conclusion that you make the department
health the client for arya
i think arya should be broadly defined
it should be able to look at
challenges and problems across the whole
domain of science and technology
so you've made clear that leadership is
vital to
arya if we get the wrong leadership is
your expectation that it will just end
up becoming
another arm of what we've got at the
moment and you've said that's
undesirable you might as well not do it
at all yes i think i think that
the strongest argument really for
against this
whole concept is um it was interesting
when i was talking to some of the
old-timers who were actually part of the
original thing so who were funded by
lick lyder and robert taylor themselves
and they said you know these people
who've won cheering medals and god knows
what
and they said one of the weird things
about about this world is
that it seems like great funders are
much rarer than
nobel prize winners and touring medal
winners and it certainly does seem that
people like general groves and george
muller who did the apollo program and
bob taylor
are very very old people um and it and
and
i think that is the chief bottleneck in
this kind of thing and
the most obvious way which you will fail
if you just get some bug standard vice
chancellor
and and put it in put them in then uh
obviously it won't work well i squeezed
one more in my time on
you you wanted weirdos and misfits with
odd skills into the civil service
clearly
reo is designed to encourage those
people in the science sphere
without going into what happened with
the civil service do you think if aria
works there will be lessons to read
across from it to other aspects of the
state including my tool
yes unquestionably
unquestionably i think uh 2020 was
a uh a proof that
if you don't have people who with um
scientific tech and technical
backgrounds who understand how to think
rationally
quantitatively about extreme uncertainty
then you can very easily have disastrous
decisions
bringing people who do have those skills
into that decision-making process
helps you avoid helps you avoid
disasters um
and i'm sure that if you can if you if
you
if you create aria in the right way then
it will have um
a very very positive effect for for
british science in general
it's interesting how how much support
there is for it globally right lots of
these people have read your books
they know what happened with in los
alamos with general groves
they know what happened with a lot of
them with lick lidar in the 60s
they they everyone can see personal
computer internet revolution
staring them in the face and scientists
themselves know how horrific the current
system is and particularly how terrible
it is for young people
i just keep stressing that it's terrible
for young people
and the strongest supporters that i've
found of this are not
um necessarily the very high very high
status people who already control
powerful labs and have huge amounts of
money
for lots of them you know the system
works works fine as it is
but that's not good for that's not good
for british science it's not good for
the world
what we really need now if you have
newton or darwin or turing
turning up now with their ideas age 20
21
everyone in the parent system would say
were you mad of course not front of you
thank you um so we've got to have a
system that can
that's open to people like that we want
to come on to some broader questions of
science funding and that's um that's a
useful introduction to that
um but i want to take a quick question
from carol who'll have a question later
on as well and i said i'd come back to
catherine
carol well thanks very much um chair
and um maybe just point out the newton
and einstein's ideas where
um sneered that whenever they first
presented them
however um dominic you've talked this
morning about the extreme
freedom um to go ahead and
explore ideas now the events of the last
year in the pandemic have taught us that
there must be checks and balances
where public money is concerned to
ensure that
cronyism is not um the the
overriding decision maker
so how do we avoid extreme freedom
leading to extreme cronyism when we're
looking at funding
um i i missed the very beginning of that
but i think i think your question is
does extreme freedom mean extreme
cronyism
um is that right yes i mean
how do we avoid if we're talking about
spending public money
how do we ensure that the extreme
freedom doesn't mean it's been spent
without checks and balances
and that it is going to those those in
such as those who have the connections
so i think um
i think that looks at the problems of
the the wrong way around
so we've we've got a procurement system
that was created by the eu framework and
then gold-plated by whitehall
i uh and others said repeatedly before
2020 this system is an expensive
disaster zone
and when it hits a crisis it will
completely
fall over so that system hit a crisis
and it and it completely fell over
but this is a system which is the
justification for it supposedly was well
we've got all of these processes and
that
means that everyone yes it might be a
bit slow but we can be sure that you
know it's all very proper and whatnot
learning the lesson from okay we've got
an extremely bureaucratic system that
can't cope with a crisis
let's make it more bureaucratic and have
more process i think is the exact
opposite lesson the the the that i would
learn
if you go back and look at the history
say of manhattan project one of you see
things was that when congress looked at
all of the
the accounts for it afterwards after the
war
not only was everyone completely
gobsmacked by how productive
and what an amazing achievement it was
but they were also completely gobsmacked
by the fact that
general groves basically ran around the
country handing out something like two
percent of us gdp
with only a handshake with absolutely no
lawyers involved no processes
at all and congress was astonished to
see that
not only how super productive that was
but also how completely free
of cronyism and corruption and
everything else
now what happened in the 60s was that
the pentagon kind of went in the
opposite direction they brought in these
hugely laborious procurement processes
and that's what actually created this
nightmare
of corruption and cronyism in the whole
us
defense industry from which it's
extremely hard
to to escape so again if you if you look
at the people who actually did these
kind of
options lately can i bring you in a bit
manhattan project you're talking about a
project that had a specific
target you're not talking about a body
with a specific target so it's quite a
different
entity that we're discussing today well
let's just briefly understand
with respect i don't think that's quite
so you're right manhattan budget did
have a specific
target of creating nuclear device before
hitler but exactly the same argument
that i'm making applies to lick lidar
and arpa in the early 60s
that did not have a specific it was not
a mission it was not an apollo type
mission
it was a one sentence vision statement
from lick glider
about interactive personal computing and
networking everybody globally
so the that and park and the old lmb at
cambridge
that shows that you can have extremely
low friction
scientific funding uh which is super
productive
and has no taint or has much less
cronyism
and much less corruption than
normal bureaucratic systems current
existing systems
massively reward high status
well-connected people
thank you let me go to catherine
fletcher i promise i'd come back
on aria for your final question that was
of your mind
on that i'm grateful to apologies
colleagues um i shall be brief
i will happily wear a badge that says i
am a bit of a scientific weirdo
and i broadly accept the idea that we
need a skunk works policy to
get the fruits of the british genius and
what we can come out with
but what that will imply is a failure
rate yes so
could you give the british public an
idea of what percent
what a good success rate looks like if
um this new area or body funds a hundred
projects
sure so you you you're completely right
everybody who
who's been involved in these sorts of
things um
at a very high level has said to me
essentially
if it isn't failing then it's failing it
has to fail
and quite a large percentage of what it
does should fail
shouldn't work if that's not the case
then it isn't taking enough risks and
it's not actually properly sampling from
the the design space that it should be
sampling from
the allen k who is one of the old-timers
still alive in his 80s
uh who's written about the original
opera and park and created a lot of the
technologies which now your phones and
whatnot will
all use his analogy is
um it's baseball
uh if you're batting 300 then then
then that's fantastic and and that's the
sort of the
that's the sort of thing he's probably
not as familiar with baseball as it
should be
so just give us an out of a hundred we
can do cricket well if you did if you if
you did if you
if you if you applied that to a hundred
projects and you took the allen k thing
then you'd say maybe a third of them are
working out brilliantly and
two-thirds of them aren't but i think
probably it's more extreme than that
right
if you look at venture capital now which
is actually an
easier business than the business of
what lick lidar is doing or what general
gross was doing with oppenheimer
almost all of their returns come from a
tiny number of successes
even the very best french capital
companies half of what they do
totally fails a lot of what they do
largely fails
and almost all their returns come from a
tiny number of
of successes and i think that that's
that's the sort of approach which which
rea needs to take that's the whole point
of having an institution like this
a lot the crucial thing there is you
learn from what's
you learn from what's failing it's the
institution
a success metric is the percentage of
failures
certainly it's one of them yes that's
that's what the people who've actually
been part of a successful thing like
this say to me
thank you very much um uh catherine are
we going to move on to
science funding more generally but just
on
the ambitions that you've you've set out
and uh
that you have for arya is
800 million pounds which is a lot of
money in the scheme of things but
okay is that adequate to the scale of
ambition and purpose that you have in
mind for this organization
um i think it's not but i think i i
think to begin with it's fine
uh because this thing will take time to
to
to to scale up um
yeah i mean if you look if you look at
the us darpa it's three billion a year
um i think that if you're thinking about
this over the over a kind of 10-year
period
the way i would look at it is you kind
of scale up with a few hundred million
um you watch what happens and you have
in the back of your mind the idea
that it could get to you know the three
three to five billion a year
type to type size in the future
um but with one big caveat
it enormously depends whether or not
you're going to use this organization
to try to do some specific missions
right so for example if you
said if you took the example i gave
earlier on how do you stop something
like covert happening again
and you say right there is a set of uh
of challenges on a five time
ten year time scale around testing
sequencing
mrna vaccines etc um
you could easily sync i think i think
the current budget that some people talk
about in the states for that sort of
thing is say 20 billion quid over 10
years
so it enormously depends whether or not
you're going to give it some things like
that are you for example gonna
can you ask it to look at some specific
things around um
let zero uh direct air carbon capture
things like that exactly if if you're
saying
right here's a here's a port of money
your job is to find
people like lick lyda people like darwin
people like turing in their early 20s
with ideas that could change
civilization completely then
you don't need a huge you don't need a
huge multi-billion pound budget for that
quite the opposite
and i just stressed you know the
original um funding that created the
internet and personal computing was only
a few hundred million dollars
over 15 years right and that's created
tens of trillions
in value so you don't need huge inputs
in order
the freedom is much what for aria to
succeed the freedom
is much much much more important than
the amount of money
spending spending large amounts of money
the same as we're doing now you'll just
get the same things
in terms of um the the critique you've
given um
of the the uk funding system with all of
its bureaucracy and
frustrations um why have
is it a reasonable charge that you
haven't been ambitious enough you've
concentrated
uh on this which is going to be a tiny
proportion of the total
rather than using your time in office to
get to grips with the
the main problem which is the
we hope 22 billion pounds of funding
that you've just described
goes through a system that is totally
unfit for purpose
yep so um in 2020
i did spend a lot of time on on on this
idea but i spent far
more time on the general problem i think
you're right uh
um it obviously doesn't make sense just
just for us all to spend our time on
creating one new agency and then even if
we get it right the rest of the system
is stuck in in all the terrible ways
it's currently stuck so i completely
agree with you and the good news is that
i think that
um otley laser is both a brilliant
scientist
and really understands a lot of the
bureaucratic problems
i think that um there's a lot of
brilliant officials in bays who
understand what the problems are and
were very supportive
of me and others in number 10 in trying
to fix that there was a lot of thinking
about
how this could be done um if i were you
i would definitely encourage this
committee to say that ottole and kwasi
should be reporting
regularly on the deep bureaucratization
of
the overall system the single biggest
problem i think you'll have there is
some senior people
we're not at all fans of this i think
that's where probably your main problem
will come
okay um what about in number 10 this was
you you said
doubling the science budget um was part
of the deal that you did
with the prime minister when you came in
you're no longer there other
is there enough support for this in in
number 10
to uh to help other eliza and and
philadelphia in the treasury
uh pursue the bureaucratization you
describe
i don't know uh is the answer to that i
mean i i hope
i hope that um
i hope that as the country emerges from
the current look down and as um
there is a
as there should be an urgent um very
very hard look by this building
into what went wrong and why in 2020
one of the most obvious lessons of that
um is this problem it's the incredible
value potentially
in getting science and technology stuff
right the disaster that can come
if you if you if you don't get it right
um all but also i i would encourage
people to think about uh you know it's
not coincidental
that the vaccine program worked the way
that it did
um it's not coincidental that to do that
we had to take it out of
the department of health we had to have
it authorized very directly
by the prime minister and say strip away
all the normal nonsense that we can see
is holding back
funding in the future we took it out of
the department of health
who who was we well in the sense that
number 10 took it another department of
health back in
so in in spring in spring 2020 you had a
situation where
department of health was just a smoking
ruin
in terms of procurement and ppe and
and all of that um
you had serious problems with the
funding bureaucracy for therapeutics on
coving
so that was the kind of context for it
patrick valence then came to number 10
says this shouldn't be run out of the
department for health we should create a
separate task force
we also had the eu proposal which uh
looked like an absolutely guaranteed
program to fail
debacle and therefore patrick violence
the cabinet secretary me and some others
said uh obviously we should take us out
of the department for health obviously
we should create a separate task force
and obviously we have to empower that
task force directly with the authority
of the prime minister
uh you know at that time as well you had
some very smart people saying
um people like bill gates saying
don't do this in a normal way start
building
like the apollo program actually exactly
like that learn the lessons from that
concurrency so start building things
like the supply chains
and the manufacturing capability now
before you do
normally there's a kind of sequential
thing you figure things out and then you
do tests and then you
do manufacturing and distribution
everything else what bill gates and a
lot of other people said was just try
and smash all of these different things
together and try and do them and try and
do them in parallel
um but to do that you needed to have a
different structure well we look forward
to going into more detail in that as
part of our lessons learned
inquiry with the joint committee with
health and social care
on the science funding system as we have
it let me turn now to some of my
colleagues
uh starting with chris lux
thank you for coming today dominic so um
obviously you've already sort of
focused on the fact that you know that
there's a serious problem with
bureaucratization and i love the word
over your occupation but how effectively
do you think
the r d uh system that currently exists
including ukri
is working in the uk and
what what's actually working and what
isn't working because you've already
talked about this sort of very sort of
the
vertical structure into having a much
lighter structure ferrari
so you you slightly sort of cut in and
cut out there i'm afraid so i couldn't i
couldn't hear brilliantly what you said
i think what you're saying is
kind of what what's wrong with the
current system around kind of university
funding and ukrai and stuff like that
so essentially you have um
you have uh you have
the the output that everyone is looking
for is pretty much identical
which is metrics like is this going to
be a paper and is it going to be a paper
in a
in a high status journal like science
and nature
the decisions are all basically made by
peer review committees
and this forces decisions very very much
to
conservative cautious incremental ideas
it's why i said earlier on that david
deutsch
one of our great physicist pioneers of
the last 50 years says
he could not get funding now for his
ideas from 1980 in the in the current
system
and the people who who approve this
funding then say that there's no way
that they will be able to
be able to do it now so you have
everyone's looking at these same metrics
you can't have software as an output you
can't have a tool like oxy
as an out as an output you have the same
kind of peer review committees looking
at everything
and all the different entities that you
go to basically operate in exactly the
same way
there's no one that you can go to and
say look what i'm doing doesn't fit into
to that into a standard uh into a
standard metric i'll give you an extreme
example that i actually spent time
trying to solve right so
an extreme example of the kind of
problem that you have
where it just doesn't make any sense is
that in pure maths
when i arrived in summer 2019 you're
applying for pure maths you had to fill
out a thing called an impact assessment
now for anybody involved with pure maths
you know this is just completely and
utterly nonsensical
like asking turing to fill out an impact
assessment in 1936
on on on his paper uh it's just
completely possible but in fact the
impact is
oh you create digital computers and you
have enigma and it's involved with
beating the nazis and everything else
but these sort of things are completely
unpredictable in advance it doesn't make
sense to try and get these people to
write these ludicrous forms
now it took me literally 18 months just
to change that
and twice we were all told that it had
been changed and twice it somehow crept
back into the system
even after it's somehow deleted from the
system it then creeps back into the
system
so all the dotted all the way through
are these kind of completely crazy
things that it's extremely difficult for
the system itself
to to to to try and fix
and that pushes everything towards
incremental improvements
extreme conservatism give money to
a lot of high status men who already
control
powerful organizations don't give it to
young people
with new ideas that's the the that i
think is the heart of the
uh of much of the current problems chris
so wouldn't it be fair to say that the
issue is that there's far too much
process
and not enough emphasis on outcomes
exactly
everyone is everyone is emailing each
other about these absurd processes for
literally month after month after month
after month after month and no no one
has the authority to say stop
so just taking that logical extreme
would you say that the app
basically we need a complete restart of
the r d process uh
an entirely new model or is it a case
that aria will sit alongside
what's already there and possibly drive
best practice i wouldn't say
i wouldn't say that you've got to just
sort of completely tear up the existing
system and start again but what you do
have to do is you have to have
you if you're going to change this you
have to have senior people
tasked with the with the authority to
say
we are going to wage war on process
because if you don't do that then uh uh
then you know it just doesn't happen and
i i spent
a vast amount of my time last year
you know the me in the media stories i'm
running around trying to have
culture wars of the bbc and whatnot in
the real world i was spending
a huge amount of my time dealing with
exactly this
problem but no it's really important to
understand that almost nobody
everyone has vetoes over everyone else
in the system almost nobody has the
power to say
just stop doing this insanity so
last year for example when the treasury
tried to have this
business case process for how pure maths
should be funded
the whole system spent literally eight
months sending emails to each other
driving everybody insane
and then finally i got the treasury
officials and some other people in a
room and said one
earth is everyone doing and the treasury
was shamed sheepish and said yeah well
we've
made a terrible mistake on this we
should drop it we're embarrassed
it goes but it takes months and months
and months of
of meetings and and whatnot to do that
and that's even when you're sitting in
the prime minister's office say the
prime minister wants this to happen
it's still incredibly hard actually in a
practical way
to remove bureaucracy from the from the
system so you'll only get it
if people like ottolin and kwasi uh
uh are tasked with that by the prime
minister and by the chancellor
and then the chancellor says to senior
treasury officials no no
we are actually deadly serious about
this we're not having a repeat of 2020
in all sorts of ways the system is going
to change
thank you chris obviously it's going to
be a much smaller
structure which followed by me
um but what safeguards do you envisage
being built into that because at the
moment obviously the layer and layer of
bureaucracy when these emails are
pinging back and forth somebody goes
that's a ridiculous idea we're not doing
that
if you've got somebody who has a good
taste in science
are they going to solve the determinants
of what goes ahead and what doesn't or
is there going to be some sort of buffer
built in there to say
actually no that is a good idea or no
that's absolutely crackers
so again again i slightly struggled on
zoom to hear what you're saying but
i think the answer to what you're saying
is that like
a critical part of this so if you go
back to how
um nikolai got his funding in arpa and
how bob taylor got the funding to do the
internet
both of them involved basically
wandering into the director's office
having a chat and the director saying
that sounds like a cracking idea go and
do it that's the famous conversation
with robert taylor in
in 67 or whatever it was on on the
arpanet
the critical thing if you're going to do
things differently
is that individuals have to be able to
place
bets not committees okay as soon as you
have committees
and a pursuit of consensus then
automatically it's basically impossible
to fund these sort of things
thank you very much um chris is one way
to deal with the bureaucracy
rather than it going through national
organizations
to to direct the money straight to
universities
for them to exercise at their discretion
uh
it it can be and it's definitely been a
strength of arpa and darpa that they
don't have that kind of empire building
themselves they don't build their own
laps and i would strongly recommend that
arya itself
does not build its own labs it funds
other people so you avoid the empire
building
problem however it's also the case that
um
in all my laborious investigations last
year on this
subject around the cabinet table that
universities themselves are also an
absolutely massive source of bureaucracy
and one of the things that in my opinion
that should happen is that the
government should be very aggressive
with universities and say
we've got a lot of money to hand out
we're going to double the science budget
you've got to do your part you've got to
remove all the following nonsense
from your maths department from your
physics department for your engineering
departments if you want
if you want our cash and and create some
really strong incentives from
universities because at the moment the
universities themselves
add another layer to all of these all
this process horror
okay thank you i'm going to go to uh
carol monaghan but
just in terms of the the deal doubling
science
the science budget was part of the the
deal
at the same time the the negotiation
with the eu
is going on including our potential
participation
in the horizon program was it intended
that the subscription to
horizon would be deducted from the
science budget
it was previously paid for as part of
our eu subscription
so it was the over over the 18 months of
from july 19 onwards those incredibly
complicated
discussions about the whole horizon
thing um my basic view of it was that
if you can do that
i suggested and david frost tried to do
this
going to the eu and saying listen let's
just take all the science stuff off the
table
separate from the main negotiations we
can all agree
that this would be better for european
civilization in the world if we can do a
separate deal on science
brussels wouldn't do that they insisted
on on keeping science as part of the
whole overall thing
so we got enmeshed in the whole process
with barney
my essential view was that we had a
moral obligation
and the prime minister committed to this
that
brexit would not take away a single
penny of any existing funding
that was my very strong view uh
it might be the manifesto i certainly
try to write it into the conservative
manifesto
um i can't remember now maybe i'm going
mad i've forgotten
but i hope it's in a manifesto uh but
that was your clear understanding of
what the deal was
without without any without any question
the prime minister said definitely said
a few times that
um we should whatever happens in terms
of the new eu negotiations
british science will not lose a penny it
doesn't come out we'll find the money to
make our work
and that's obviously what should happen
okay um same question on
uh oda funding i don't know whether you
were in number 10 when
uh when the discussions about having a
temporary cut to
older funding were taking place yes some
of that quite a lot of that
funds science research
was it intended that that should reduce
the science budget
uh certainly not intended by me no i
could see
there was definitely a strong argument
that the chancellor made
for making a temporary reduction in the
in the odor
budget overall my view was
that because of how budgets are done
there's a natural tendency in whitehall
to try and double count things
to try and say oh well if you put a
pound in that pot then it counts
for oda and accounts for science and it
counts for the assigned accounts for
that
my view very strongly was that whatever
we did
whether it's horizon or oda um shouldn't
be subject to kind of
um to to whitehall accounting gimmicks
okay thank you um let me go to carol
monaghan and then rebecca on bailey
thanks very much um i'm
struggling to understand you've you've
given particular examples of
difficulties with the existing funding
system
and i'm struggling to understand why you
consider the best way of tackling
difficulties with how science is
currently funded
is by setting up a whole new different
agency
now we're talking about really a small
amount for this agency 800 million is a
small amount of the overall science
budget
so surely we would be better actually
dealing with the vast majority of
science funding and how it's allocated
within ukri
rather than tinkering about with a small
amount
probably less than one percent of of
what
um we have in order to set up a new
agency could you maybe explain that
so i i thought i thought um
obviously i wasn't clear before um
i don't think at all that all of the
focus should go on creating a new agency
i don't think it's either or i think
that they they're all to be i made huge
efforts
i made more efforts last year to try and
deal with the overall system than i did
with
trying to create a new agency but it's
not either all i think we
we certainly have to make huge efforts
to improve the the
the basic system um the problems that we
had last year
uh dealing with covid are
make the case extremely eloquently for
why
the overall general system must change
but you also could have
a small niche entity which is free of
all the existing
sys rules regulations as well i don't
think it's
either or i think there is more than
enough money to be able to do
to to to do both and again i would
stress what what i already said
it doesn't need huge amounts of cash the
the
the the computing research in open 60s
and 70s was a few hundred million
dollars in today's money
so it doesn't need a huge amount of
money it's the freedom
for people to act in a low friction way
which is really the the the critical
thing carol
and it so you were very keen that
science funding
was increased significantly and what
were the
the key threats that you considered
were require this additional
spend of money uh
well i mean if you go back and look at
lots of things that i've
been writing over the last 10 years um
there's lots of things
that i wrote about how um
[Music]
about how there's tremendous
opportunities
to invest in science and technology to
change the world for the for the better
but also we need to make this a core
focus of the british state because if we
don't it's incredibly dangerous
um i mean back in summer uh i think june
or something 2019 only a month before i
went into number 10
i wrote a long thing about um about
science policy about decision making
about expertise about how the cabinet
room would collapse
in a serious crisis because because of
how it's set up etc
etc and if you don't take science and
technology
seriously you don't have the kind of
skills needed
in the apex of power in the state then
it can be extremely dangerous and you've
got these dangers multiplying
all the time you've got dangers on
pandemics you've got
dangers on engineered pandemics
you've got uh problems of the last 70
years
we still today you have nuclear weapons
or launch on warning which is a massive
massive uh nightmare
so all of these or both in a positive
sense
of the value you can create in in the
kind of defensive sense of the disasters
you can avoid
um i've been arguing for for 10 years
that
that science and technology should be
should be seen as a core part of what
the prime minister's job is
um and in fact the very last meeting i i
ever had the last discussion i had with
the prime minister the day that i left
down the street was actually on this
subject
was about how to shift how to change the
bureaucratic strategies inside number 10
in the cabinet office
so that you make science and technology
a core part
not just of the current prime minister's
job but all future prime minister's
jobs and again i think that uh
obviously i've been saying this for 10
years i think that last year
uh just makes it obvious
thank you i don't think any of us in
this committee would disagree with the
importance of science and technology
and the government has a target of 2.4
percent
of gdp is is this realistic
uh i don't know i don't
know i also don't think it's enough
either um
i think that uh as a country we should
be aiming
both for so for me the doubling was only
if it was the first time so
i think doubling the science budget is a
critical thing and a good thing
uh improving how the general system
works is
alongside it is necessary so that money
is not just wasted
in brackets i'd point out i think nih
doubled its budget
in the states over the last 10 20 years
but they didn't change how the money was
spent and therefore
doubling it basically has had no impact
um
so changing it uh uh changing how the
money is spent is just started
more important than increasing the
budget but i think long term
um we should be looking at more
than the current plan i think we should
be looking at um
at having much longer term budgets the
other big problem inside ukri
and one of the big differences between
ukrai at the moment
and the normal science funding process
at the moment
and a great entity like the 60s arpa or
bell labs is
their inability to plan long term which
is incredibly
damaging for for science
so i think 2.4 percent this
they should they should be aiming at
that the government should be doing its
part of that
government the government should be
spending proportionately
at least as much as the countries around
the world
that are doing the most on this so
places like korea china
et cetera um instead of languishing at
the bottom of the g7 or g20 lists
we should be aspiring to be at the top
of those lists
but i stress how the money is spent is
even more important than just increasing
the amount of money
thank you very much indeed um we'll now
go to rebecca long bailey but just to
pick up on the
point that you made to carol about your
last conversation with the prime
minister
um was about moving the
the administration of science into the
cabinet office um
presumably from from base is that is
that right yes
conversations are two way did the prime
minister agree with with that proposal
yes there was a note uh that i wrote
with patrick valence which
which i actually gave to the pm on in my
very last conversation with him and said
um you should approve this and he gave
it back to the private secretary and
said
approved and so hopefully that is
actually what's happening
so the cabinet secretary uh patrick
valance
me ottolin various people had a lot of
discussions
last year obviously partly in a kind of
learning lessons from covert way
about how the center of government
thinks about science and technology
about this basic problem of of how to
coordinate across the whole system when
you've got warring departments
and multiple veto points and multiple
bureaucracies kind of locked with each
other and no one being able to
break log jams and
and that's why patrick valance and i and
the cabinet secretary said
um the the code system is obviously no
good and it should change very
significantly
and the current cabinet secretary
[Music]
is a strong supporter for making science
and technology
call to the job of the prime minister
for the future
so the proposal is to bring it into the
heart of government
under number 10 and that's both the
response to the
the learnings of the pandemic but also
to deal with the
the increased scale of investment in
science that is
is now yeah because it's exactly it it's
only
that with the best will in the world the
junior science minister of bays
can't look across the whole system and
have authority
in in terms of how white will work so
this you have a theoretical conversation
about what's the platonic idea of how to
do this
but that's not the situation that we
were in
last year what i was looking at was
what's
practically sort of just about
possible given how whitewall currently
operates and the
whole departmental structure and whatnot
um
unless you rip up really much more
fundamental things about how whitehall
works which personally i would be in
favor of
um you need a way for the
center to be able to look at right what
are the big so
say you know you've got things like net
zero coming through right you've got
huge net zero
uh obligations an action
you've got huge defense and intelligence
obligations you've got the normal
science budgets
you've got clover's response you've got
all these sorts of things
the current system hasn't had no way to
read to coordinate
thinking about all of this to think what
are the real priorities
and then actually project manage them
project management through the system
and drive it through whitehall that
can't be done by junior based ministers
it could only be done if you have
the in the current system actually it's
extraordinarily hard even for the prime
minister's office to get anything done
like this
as last year showed but it certainly has
no chance of happening
unless it has the authority of the prime
minister and the chancellor okay thank
you very much indeed rebecca long bailey
then mark logan
thanks chair and thanks dominic for
coming to speak to us today
i think you've been very diplomatic on
government funding so far
and the possibilities emanating from an
arthur afro-style body could be immense
for the initial 800 million pounds for
area which incidentally has been pushed
back now until 2024-25
it wasn't a vast amount of money when
you compare it to the nearly three
billion dollars the u.s spends on darpa
as you've mentioned earlier
but on the budget itself this year there
was no additional funding
announced for arya in there and further
announcements on science funding were
also
scarce indeed the treasury hasn't made
any funding available
to support the uk's association to
horizon which will need to be met from
existing
science budgets and the oda allocation
to ukri is reduced significantly
leading to 120 million pounds worth of
shortfall so what did you make of the
budget
in relation to r d do you think the
government's being ambitious enough
or do you feel that they're at risk of
watering down your ambitions
certainly on on the oba and horizon
point they seem to be doing the opposite
of what you'd like to see based on your
comments today
so i didn't i didn't watch the budget
and i don't really have any idea what
what was in it um i'll take obviously
what you say is fact um if if ukrai
budgets have been cut then that's
obviously
um uh extremely bad
decision uh i don't know why that would
have happened um in the budgets that i
had
in the documents that i had with the
numbers pencilled in when i left in
november
ukri was getting very generous
improvements to the
its core budgets um not just for this
year but throughout the next
um through the whole spending review
period and through 20
20 25. so if that's changed in the last
12 weeks
uh then that's obviously bad
um and if there's dodgy accountancy
tricks with odor and whatnot then uh
i agree with you that's also obviously
bad i mean
if 2020 isn't enough of a of a
galvanizing shock to say we should ought
to take science and technology seriously
and both fund it properly and embedded
in government decision making
intelligently and strip out the
bureaucracy that causes so much harm
that i don't know what would be rebecca
thanks dominic well you didn't need to
watch the budget you didn't really miss
much when it comes to science and r d
but it's interesting really that the
government has said that it was
committed to making the uk
a global science superpower and that its
r
d funding plans would help accelerate
our ambition to reach 2.4
of gdp are spent on r d by 2027
however with the recent budget and the
scarcity
of increased funding for science there's
a real worry
that the 2.4 figure which i agree with
you
isn't big enough anyway it could simply
be met really by the collapse in
britain's gdp
since the pandemic started rather than a
real terms
increase in funding so my question to
you is do you think
that the government's intentions are to
rely on meeting its 2.4 target through
falling gdp and what would you like to
see the government do going forward in
terms of real
r d funding and you've said that 2.4
isn't enough i agree what percentage of
gdp should we be spending
on r d
um so as a as i said i stress
i don't know what i don't know what
decisions were made after i left and i
don't know what was
what was in the budget i know that rishi
himself was always a very strong
supporter
of r d spending in in in
arguments between number 10 the cabinet
office the treasury in different parts
of whitehall
over 18 over the nine months or whatever
that he was
he was chancellor uh rishi always said
that
the two big things that he wanted to
prioritize was science and technology
spending and um and the skills agenda
the allison wolf
skills agenda to try and solve that uh
century-long problem
um so i think he personally is
definitely is definitely committed to it
um
personally i wouldn't focus so much at
the moment obviously there's gdp numbers
are bouncing around all over the shop
because of the because of last year
i don't think that that's really the
target to aim for i would i would
personally i would aim
i would look at what the absolute
numbers are i think it would be
completely crazy to say
okay well gdpr sorry gdp has taken this
huge
um hit from covid therefore 2.4 percent
of it is much less therefore we can cut
science funding but still somehow say
that we're meeting the target
that would just be completely insane um
what we should be doing is looking at
real terms real terms budgets
and increasing them up to the 22
that was originally envisaged and
committed to back in march
where it should go in the future i think
you know thousands of people have much
better
much better idea than me about what what
that should look like but
it's obvious that places like china and
korea are taking science and technology
much more seriously than britain has
done over the last 10 years it's obvious
that david cameron and george osborne
did not take this remotely seriously as
they should have done
they didn't fund it uh as seriously as
they should have done and
we've paid uh price in all sorts of ways
for their
in my opinion terrible terrible
decisions um
we should be now now you've got
situation where both china is
saying we're going to spend huge amounts
of vast amounts of money over the next
20 years
um particularly things like ai the biden
administration
uh is reversing trump's uh
trajectory and is saying it's going to
spend a huge amount of money as well
so i think you know there is going to be
a lot of pressure on on
on britain that there'll be pressure on
where great talent will go
to some extent british science benefited
from trump in that people were
looking to get out of that system and
didn't have confidence in it long term
um so some people came over here from
the states now with what binds doing
the opposite sort of gravitational pull
could could potentially come into effect
so i think
um britain can't match obviously pound
for pound what china's spending and what
america's spending
but i go back to my to my chart
earlier on they're almost all of what
they're spending is in this red
is in this red circle if britain decides
to do things differently
then it could have very dramatic
improvements and this is not a theory
this is not my this is not
my theory this is demonstrated
historically we know that if you do it
differently you can capture this
these great returns so we should be
looking to spend
proportionately at least as much money
as the countries that are most
aggressive about this on the face of the
planet
but we should also be more aggressive
than them
in terms of attacking bureaucracy and in
terms of trying new ideas
thank you very much indeed um uh can we
go to mark logan now
thank you very much for coming in this
morning my questions are quite broad and
linked to
what becky has just asked we we've had
the integrated review
yesterday and our aim is to secure our
status as a science and tech
superpower by i mean currently do you
feel that we are an
s t superpower and how will arya
an integrated review help us cement that
position
um i think
it's well it's it's obviously patchy
right there's that there are some
fields in which we in which we are a
superpower
um the uh uh
most of the first thing that comes to
mind is is
what's happened recently with genetic
sequencing of the covalent variants and
things like that
we do have very very strong life
sciences
people like john bell at oxford
um so there are
areas where we do where where british
uh researchers are doing world-class
stuff but there's also
i was left in no doubt in my 18 months
in government talking to these people
that there is a feeling that we all
we are falling behind overall um
globally i think that's i think that's
also the case so
we definitely have you know there's
great universities like oxford cambridge
but i think increasingly the nobel
prizes of the past
are being used for branding
and we're not we haven't invested over
the last 20 years the way that we should
have done
to make sure that the pipeline of these
things is continuing um
and it's certainly the case that's the
that our best researchers are very
worried about this
um and they expressed this concern to me
and uh i was certainly very concerned
about it
so um
we have got some brilliant things we
should reinforce those brilliant things
but i think the true situation is more
worrying
uh and dangerous than it is than it
appears
um that's probably how i would summarize
it mark
dominic um just to comment on that so
the um i know you've mentioned
east asia and china and i'm reminded of
the uh
sci-fi novelist uh leo who wrote santi
or the free body problem
and he kind of said he was asking where
do you get all your great ideas for for
science fiction and he said that i
realized by living in china that i was
living in the future
do you feel that we have anything
to to learn from china or indeed any
other countries in the region
and um and also just recently
i know that the government has taken a
different
kind of step change on industrial
strategy and i'm just thinking to some
of the stuff you were saying in terms of
short-termism versus long-termism and
just keen on your thoughts on that
um yes i think i i think that uh
i think that we do have huge amounts to
learn from east asia i think that
um one of the so after i was in the
department for education
um 10 years ago one of the things i
wrote about about that experience was
how parochial it was as an institution
and how unwilling it was to look to
learn
and in particular how unwilling it was
to to try and learn from east asia
uh i think you saw exactly the same
problem in whitehall last year in a
whole
in a whole range of subjects um
i think that's what china and other
countries are doing
about making science and technology call
to their policy it's not a kind of the
way that britain has
sort of thought about it for the last 50
years it's a kind of add-on
it's what the buffings do in white coats
but it's not really what serious
politicians think about
it's not what the the top mandarins in
the cabinet office and whatnot think
about
uh i think that mindset has been
amazingly
uh damaging for the country it means
that
we haven't funded things properly we
haven't taken things seriously that we
should have taken seriously
i hope that one of the lessons of 2020
is to
change is to change course from that um
uh if you look at what the uh you know
the president
of china is actually you know actually
sits down for days on
end with senior management in around him
and has sessions on things like
uh funding edge of the art science and
technology programs
for the long term and i think
if we don't if if we don't pay attention
to that
then we will suffer enormously
um also china and russia have had
extremely aggressive operations against
this country
to acquire british knowledge
both legally and illegally overtly and
covertly
because these countries take it deadly
seriously
and cameron osborne did not take it
deadly seriously and in all sorts of
ways they left the country open to
and vulnerable um and
that's one of the many areas in which i
think scientific technology policy
must must change thank you we could
definitely learn a little differently
briefly sorry chair just briefly and
dominic on in the industrial strategy
um what would be your views in terms of
that purchasing our
science and tech um price
yeah i think well so i think there's
there's a critical distinction to make
that that's um that
the state should not be in the business
of trying to figure out
is bill gates or steve jobs right should
we support microsoft or should we
support apple in terms of consumer
consumer products i think so i think an
idea of going back
back to the future with industrial
policy of that kind i think would
just be a huge would be a huge mistake
but
um i do think and i spent uh
so i in 2020 i spent far more time
talking about
industrial policy and productivity the
productivity challenges that i did on
on all political and communications
things put together
i think that that should be should
become a core element of
of what number 10's doing and you have
to think across the whole pipeline from
funding the kind of core basic pure
research stuff
through the applied research missions
moon shots that sort of stuff
through to the kind of overall
productivity challenges
skills planning law high skilled
immigration you know all of these things
i actually started so while pmq's was
going on i used to run a set of me i
didn't
have anything to do with pmq's i used to
have a separate set of meetings called
project speed
for much of 20 2020 where we would get
some of the great officials around
whitehall
and pull them together from different
departments trying to figure out how to
do this
sort of thing i hope that that's still
going on and there was certainly a huge
number of very
corrective ideas and certainly rishi was
a great supporter
of this and put the institutional weight
of the treasury behind doing it
so i hope that a lot of that work will
come out over the next few months
thank you very much indeed graeme
stringer had
a supplementary question he wanted to
ask before we conclude
so thanks very much donick it's been a
fascinating
hour and a half just
i suppose it's a bit of an open goal but
90
of scientists voted to remain
in the eu one of the reasons they gave
was that the eu sponsored
cooperation between different scientific
institutions and universities
within the eu it was my feeling in
debate and talking to scientists
that cooperation and hitting that
metric became more important than the
science in in terms of those projects
i wonder if you agree
yes i do uh and unsurprisingly i mean
obviously in the referendum one of the
things that you and i
argued very strongly was that um it
would be very dangerous to let the eu
continue to regulate science and
technology in this country
and that we should take back control of
regulation over
science technology procurement and again
i would argue very strongly that
2020 was a uh proof
that that that that argument was
was correct i could understand
completely the the view of many
scientists that they wanted to maintain
cooperation across european networks
um i think that's obviously correct but
i think you know as as things are being
proved every day now
scientists can cooperate globally
without having to be part
of the nightmarish brussels system
which has blown up so disastrously over
vaccines
just this week we've seen uh what
happens when you have an anti-science
anti-entrepreneurial anti-technology
culture in brussels
married with its appalling bureaucracy
in its insane decisions over
uh warnings on the astrazeneca vaccine i
think we're
we are extremely well out of that
system thank you very much indeed um
just a couple of um
final ones uh from me the the integrated
review was uh published
uh yesterday it has a very strong
role for science in fact it's the the
first pillar to sustaining strategic
advantage through science and technology
i think those of us on this committee
would welcome that
is there a danger though do you see that
it can fall into the
the double counting trap that if you've
got this target
of 2.4 percent of 22 billion pounds
that existing work whether it's in the
mod or elsewhere
is declared to be science
funding and it doesn't come anywhere
near
boosting the overall budget for uh for
universities and research institutes
um yes so i think uh i think that um
it's great that the that science and
technology is core to
to to the plan for the future in defence
and security
and in terms of performing mod um
the chief scientific adviser there
angela
uh i work with a lot is fantastic and i
think she will
use that money um incredibly well
there is obviously uh uh potentially a
danger about
um double counting accountancy gimmicks
but you know in the end
that responsibility is going to lie on
on on number 10 how much they actually
pro
are going to prioritize science and
technology in the future as i stressed
rishi was always extremely supportive of
me in these arguments
across whitehall when as chancellor
so i'm sure that he hasn't changed his
mind and he will continue to be
very supportive um
but yes there is a danger also of course
the mod
has a roughly 10 billion pound black
hole in his budget because of decisions
made
with uh cameron was born back in 2010
and 2015 reviews which were which were
disastrous
part of the reason why we've had to put
more money in
the way that we have done is to try for
the first time in over
in probably 30 years to actually have
honest accounting
so the other also the cabinet secretary
did a brilliant job last year the new
cabinet secretary
i spent many hours with him around the
cabinet table and a small group of
people from the mod
in which they said themselves for the
first time since the end of cold war
we've actually got honest numbers on the
table between the mod the treasury
number 10 and the governor office
and so there are proper figures
i know that there are proper figures on
spreadsheets that exist i hope that
those are the figures that are actually
being
used and that the system doesn't slide
back into its old ways
which leads me to my final question you
say you you hope
it's clear that one of your ambitions
and motivations was to
to make or reinforce britain's position
as a science
superpower you had the position in
number 10 to be able to
to do that did you consider whether it
was necessary for
for you to to leave and do you regret
the fact that you're
no longer able to to steer that
personally
um no i don't i don't regret that
uh i think i made the right decision to
resign when
when i did um i actually said to the
prime minister back in july
that i would leave by friday the 18th of
december at the latest
so it wasn't the whole thing was not
exactly as it
as it appeared but as i said earlier on
i'd be i'll be very happy to come back
and answer any and all questions about
how number 10 works where i left
all the different um things uh crazy
stories that have been in the media
um i'd be happy to clarify all of those
uh
whenever you guys want me to come back
and talk about that well thank you very
much indeed i think we've covered a lot
of ground
today uh on aria specifically
and science funding the structure of
science funding which was the the
subject of the committee's inquiry we're
very grateful for your evidence on that
which will help inform the debate and
scrutiny in the house of commons
as we consider the bill to establish
aria we have as you say a joint
inquiry into the lessons that we can
learn
and apply from the handling of the
pandemic joint with the health and
social care
committee so we look forward to seeing
you back to answer some more questions
on those subjects at that time thank you
very much indeed for your evidence today
that concludes this segment of the
the hearing we're going to suspend
briefly uh to invite the secretary of
state to join us
thank you thank you very much thank you
for everyone's
opportunities and attention and effort
that you've made to try and help the
science and technology
agenda thank you thank you very much
currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
the proceeding is currently suspended
order order the committee is back in
session we're continuing
our questions about science policy
science funding and in particular the
new aria
research uh agency very pleased to uh
welcome
for their i think both their first
appearances before this committee
uh the secretary of state for business
energy and industrial strategy
quasi-quarten and joe muglingham who is
the director general uh responsible for
science at the department
uh for business energy industrial
strategy uh thank you very much indeed
thank you
for joining us uh um just to
to start with some questions about
science uh policy and science funding
um does the the government stand by the
commitment
made in the manifesto in queen's
speeches and other foreign
uh to the 2.4 target for r d
spending by 2027 and 22 billion pounds
of science public uh funding for science
by 2024
25. absolutely we remain uh totally
committed
to those targets very good chairman
excellent uh and in terms
of uh deploying that um and making sure
that the institutions
have the money to spend has the budget
for ukri which is the the main
research funding organization has it
been set
yet for the next financial year it's
still uh being
discussed with treasury and also with
bayes there are a number of
pressures as you'll appreciate on the
budget given where we are with kovid
and we're still in those negotiations in
that conversation
but it's two weeks till the beginning of
the the next financial i'm fully
conscious of when the
next financial year starts mr clark um
and we're very keen to get some sort of
resolution uh pretty soon
you you picked up the portfolio we know
in uh in in january and
um there's there's a lot to do as you
say for the reasons that you say but
but you will understand that for a
an agency that makes long-term
commitments
not to know its budget two weeks before
the financial year starts is
it's not happy it's very difficult and
but you'll also appreciate that uh
after 407 billion pounds have been
committed
uh to the economy over the course of the
last year
this is an unprecedented uh pressure uh
on budgets
and we're in the process of uh trying to
get a good settlement for ukri
so when do you think those conclusions
when they
think those conversations will conclude
certainly before
be before the start of the next
financial year all right so in the next
couple of weeks
absolutely okay um and
just give us a bit of background as to
what what is the reason for the delay is
it because
of money being spent on other things or
uh there's a whole range of things that
we've uh tried to
button down um there's the horizon issue
which i'm sure you'll uh revert back to
in your questioning
um where there's a whole range of issues
relating to the covid
uh situation pandemic which was
announced
in the budget and that uh will have an
impact on public finances
and also we're introducing uh the aria
bill which is separate
uh as i'm sure mr cummings pointed out
but that's part of a wider discussion as
well okay
let me go to dawn butler
thank you very much chair thank you
secretary of state um
we just heard from dominic cummings and
i just want to talk a little bit about
ukri it was formed in 2018
and it's barely kind of gotten off the
ground it was kind of made
clear that there is a problem with the
process when it comes to funding
science i'm just wondering is it wise to
prioritize a new agency rather than
making ukri
more flexible with a visionary high risk
high payoff science division so i think
mr cummings made a good answer to that
point
what arya is trying to do is
fundamentally different
from what ukrai is set to do they're
different
types of organization even though
there's an overlap they fundamentally do
different things aria is about
agility nimbleness and also has a higher
risk
appetite as dominic cummings suggested
ukri is the main funding body
of our academic research and that does
it does a great job
i think the pool nurse the pool nurse's
review of 2015
really set out the vision for ukri and
the whole point of it
was that it had a cross research view
arya doesn't have that arya is a
different
uh beast and should be thought of in
a in a totally different way i
totally understand that and i can in
some respects see the need
for uh aria
but what i'm saying is in the bill it
doesn't seem to make any connection to
ukrai and that seems quite strange and
as it's our uk
research uh scientific research
fundamental
i don't think it's i don't think it's
strange at all i mean the bill i've got
the bill in front of me
and you will appreciate that a lot of
this legislation has got to be as
concise as possible
and i don't think it would make any
sense uh in a standalone bill it's a
standalone independent
entity it wouldn't make any sense to to
refer to
ukrai explicitly in the in the bill
which is designed
to set up aria
um arya's exempt from freedom of
information
requests and it it will be able to spend
taxpayers cash
in any way that it likes and do you
think that may raise alarm bells for
some people with the recent
pp scandals i think uh you raise a fair
point but
you've referred to the bill and i'll
refer back to it if you look at the bill
the schedule one of the bill has uh a
number of
sub-clauses which deal explicitly with
the corporate
governance arrangements of arya i think
they're very robust
i as the secretary of state or my
successor will have to report to
parliament
on arya there is a duty on the part of
arya to
submit accounts these will also be
scrutinized
by parliament so i reject any idea that
this is somehow going to be outside the
normal
corporate governance structure and i
think there'll be a great deal of of
transparency and oversight dawn you
can't see but
um joe charmugallingham um was
indicating that she wanted to
say i think something about the the
relationship with ukrai
yeah so i think um so you're exactly
right with sort of through the bill
setting up this new research funding
agency and we'll come back more to the
purposes of that
but absolutely at the same time we're
continuing to support and develop ukri
appointed an excellent new chief
executive last summer they've been doing
great work
since then on reducing bureaucracy of
the funding system
and as we set out in the r d roadmap
last summer
we'll be shortly um commencing an
independent review of
bureaucracy across the whole funding
system um
universities research funding agencies
and all the other actors
to absolutely make sure this is not just
about concentrating on aria
it is absolutely about making sure we
make the best of the whole funding
system
of which ukri will always be the sort of
the critical engine and the sort of the
core of the system
thank you thank you thank you that does
add guarantee because actually
in order for arya to exist it needs to
be outside of the bureaucracy it needs
to have the freedom
and so but it does need to have some um
transparency around that and my last
question please chair um
if it's going to be uh scientists that
are on the very edge
the cutting edge of scientific
development
is can the secretary of state really is
the right person to lead
arya i mean how would how would
the secretary of state know exactly
what's happening because this would be
cutting edge technology that
you know you really would need to be
deep into it to understand it
and also how would we be able to monitor
if say aria was to
do research about eugenics so look there
are two
forgive me there are two issues here
there's the actual leader of arya
which is independent that's someone that
we're going to be recruiting and he or
she
whoever it is i'm sure will be an
excellent leader of the organization
and then there's of course the the
parliamentary and governance oversight
where the secretary of state has uh
necessarily has a role
because uh he or she after all will be
the person
that will be summoned to committees like
this to
uh explain what arya is doing so there
are two issues there's a governance
role where the secretary of state has a
key role to play
but the secretary of state will not be
determining on a day-to-day basis
uh what the missions of arya will be uh
nor will the secretary of state be
funneling uh money if that's a way of
describing it
to individual projects there is a
separation
in terms of the operation of arya which
will be run by
a director and of course the governance
and the responsibility
uh to the house of commons and
parliament
thank you very much indeed uh dawn uh
next is carol monaghan then rebecca long
bailey
thank you i'll ask questions about
ukraine just a second but
but first of all secretary of state and
how
will will the government ensure there's
oversight to
um to ensure that arya is fully
representative of the developed nations
in terms of funding allocation
i think um you raise an excellent point
and obviously in setting up this new
body we want it to reflect
the wide talent and geographical spread
of the united kingdom so there's
absolutely going to be certainly from my
point of view
uh a real interest in making sure that
that uh
is represented now in the and i've
referred to schedule one of the
uh of the bill uh there are actually
specific things where the secretary of
state is involved in appointing
perhaps non-executive members of the
board
and governance and that's an area even
though it's not expressed in the bill
where we can actually i think do a much
better job than we have done
traditionally
in representing uh you know the full
breadth and width of
the united kingdom thank you because
that is a concern that is raised
regularly
with myself and others is the spread of
funding and
how it is still concentrated in in
london in the south east
um if i move on to spending a review the
announcement of 14.6 billion for
rnd for 2021-22
and was welcomed but will this include
the contribution for horizon europe or
would that be considered as a separate
funding um that is a subject of
the conversations that i was uh
referring to to your chair
um and i think we have um we have
further uh conversations we have
further um debate if you like within
government but it'll be concluded very
very soon and joe do you want to add
anything on that yeah so absolutely so
the
um very welcome decision to associate to
horizon europe
obviously happened after the spending
review so obviously therefore
wasn't part of those spending
allocations and as the secretary of
state said
you know discussions continue about how
our association to horizon europe is
funded
and i think it you will alert the
committee whenever you find that
information
where the urbana decisions made
absolutely
i mean it's absolutely right that your
um committee
gets very early sight of when when
things are decided
what's happening thank you and and
looking at horizon europe secretary
understand that you're aware that
that there have been moves to exclude
associated members from certain quantum
and space funding streams um what
actions
are you taking to ensure that these do
remain within the funding model from
horizon
we've tried very hard and we still are
trying
to make sure that this this funding is
protected
um i think forgive me i think that we
will get make some progress in this area
and i'm hopeful
that we can essentially be members of
verizon on the basis
that we've historically been
carol apologies okay
cheers um emily and
the news the ukri m
has a reduction in oda funding
which is a necessary part of global
cooperation
and we're all very interested in global
cooperation
um in the last year um
ukri have said this will lead to a 120
million pound gap between allocations
and commitments is this also going to
impact
non-oda funded work as well um
as i said we've got to just wait and see
where the negotiations come to
i think in terms of the odor reductions
we've said these are very very difficult
decisions to make but the chancellor
made a decision to reduce
uh odor commitment from 0.7 of gdp to
0.5
percent to gdp he made very explicitly
the case that this was an exceptional uh
an exceptional policy
and that we would try and revert we will
revert to 0.7 as soon as
the fiscal situation uh permits and that
was
uh almost the exact words of uh that was
printed yesterday in the integrated
review where we made a very clear
commitment i think it was on page five
to getting back to 0.7 percent as soon
as the fiscal situation
is causing concern as whenever the
fiscal situation
um allows i mean that could be any time
really
um and is there any move from ukri
or will there be any move from
government to replace the ukri
funding that has been lost as a result
of this we we made up we
remain absolutely committed miss monahan
to
the 2.7 target that your chairman
referred to the 2.4 percent rather
target that your
chairman referred to by 2027 and
we are absolutely committed to making
sure that
we spend enough uh to make sure that we
are a science superpower that remains a
robust commitment
uh which i can reinforce today thank you
very much indeed
rebecca long bailey thank you and thank
you both for joining us today
secretary as you've heard there's a
confirmed 120 million
shortfall for research funded from the
oda budget
further yesterday following the
integrated review universities uk as i'm
sure you'll be aware wrote to government
stating that universities are
increasingly alarmed
by reports that the treasury has not
made funding available to support the
uk's association to horizon
and they say that if this position is
maintained it will amount to an
effective cut in excess of 1 billion
equivalent to the loss of over 18 000
full-time
academic research posts so are the cuts
in oda funding for science and the
potential requirements for ukri i know
you haven't
stated what's going to happen yet but
those requirements for
the ukri have gone to horizon from
existing budgets
really consistent with the government
aims to increase funding for research
i think you make a fair point i've said
this a number of
uh times i think there is a huge
pressure on public finances we've got
very ambitious commitments as far as the
science superpower agenda is concerned
yet today we're in very straightened
circumstances there's been a huge demand
uh on on the public uh finances uh the
treasury has
put in as i said 407 billion pounds into
the economy in the in the past year
and uh we've had to reduce the
proportion of
gdp that we put into odor money and that
has an effect clearly
but my job as secretary of state is to
try and make the case
for science funding and that's what i'm
doing and that's why
as your chairman suggested we are we're
engaged in ongoing
negotiations within the government
ongoing talks within the government
thank you secretary you've reaffirmed
the 2.4
commitment of gdp on r d but there's a
real possibility that the cuts that i've
referred to
could be masked by the 2.4 percent
simply being met by a collapse in
britain's gdp since the pandemic started
rather than
real terms increases in funding that
will
be altering this percentage to account
for this fall
in gdp so i think there are a lot of
assumptions in your question i mean i
don't think
that the uh the quantum of gdp
uh will be lower in 2027 than it is
today i mean that's
predicting an appalling collapse of the
economy i think the economy will grow
in fact the obr uh in the in the budget
suggested that the economy will be
growing
every year uh from now until 2027 and i
expect that the 2.4 percent
will be considerably more in real terms
as well as nominal terms
uh than it is today thank you and
finally secretary on medical research
there are a number of medical research
charities that have warned
that the significant impact of code with
19 on their budgets for funding research
and responding to the budget recently
the association for medical research
charity said that the government had
chosen yet again
not to provide any clear support for
charity funded medical research
in the budget so how does the government
intend to support medical research going
forward to address the shortfalls that
charities are currently facing again i
think you that's a very fair point
to raise i'm very pleased actually only
last week i spoke to
michelle michelle i can't remember her
name actually michelle mitchell that's
right the cancer research uk
and michelle was very clear with me that
there has to be some sort of settlement
there has to be some degree to which the
government is prepared to meet
medical research charities and fund the
difference now obviously that's a
difficult uh conversation to have
but we're looking at ways of engaging
with her and her colleagues in other
charities
to make sure that we can actually
provide the support that
is under a lot of pressure because as
you know a lot of
uh their private uh donors individuals
who are very generous uh have also been
squeezed and that's why
uh we're in the difficult position we're
in
thank you very much indeed uh rebecca
when i turn to chris clarkson
thank you chair and thank you for coming
today secretary of state um
later today we're going to be debating
uh both
breaking up the union and brexit so i
thought i'd take the opportunity to ask
about the shared prosperity fund
firstly could you tell us when that's
likely to be announced
um my understanding is that that will be
announced uh later this year
it's as you know being a subject of
ongoing discussion
i certainly remember talking about the
uk shared prosperity fund
when i was pps to philip hammond when he
was chancellor this is something that's
been ongoing
but clearly once we have the deal this
is work that we can accelerate and we
hope i think
at the end of uh at the end of this year
to have much greater clarity as to what
uh the quantum of the fund and perhaps
as to how it will be distributed
and will part of that fund be um
explicitly advocated for research and
innovation
um i think the the the way the fund
works will be very much specifically
uh centered around place so it'll be
centered around uh the geographies
uh of uh the the uk as far as i know
there hasn't been an explicit allocation
to r d but clearly we've got to work out
what the quantum of the fund is
before we can actually put labels as to
on to what the
the funding which needs the funding will
will meet um i think that uh r
d is something which clearly is very
close to the
what the government's trying to do um
but i'm not sure that the uk
what the role of the uk shared
prosperity fund will be in that context
i'm sure joe will
be able to shed light on that joe yes so
the spending review um november last
year set out
the main strategic elements of the
future uk spf
and as the secretary of state said later
this year an investment framework will
be
published and the multi-year spending
profiles we expect to be confirmed
at the comprehensive spending review we
also have the
uk community renewal fund which through
its one-year pilots will help to inform
but i think absolutely we're very
conscious of the role that the
predecessor funds have played
combining with some of the national
research funding we provide to support
research and innovation in particular
locations and those are the discussions
which will happen in government
through the course of this year well
that but i think the point just to add
in on that i think joe makes a very good
point but the
the point is that the r d offer has
actually come through uh previous funds
as well so
how the uk spf fits into that
um is still i think a match of
discussion
thank you just very quickly picking up
on that because joe mentioned uh
multi-year settlements will there be
a provision for long-term funding like
the eu structural investments funds
uh previously did do you want to come in
on that
i i think that's something that um the
treasury i'm sure we'll be considering
as part of the comprehensive spending
review i don't think
we can speak for them here today i'm
afraid okay thank you
uh thank you uh for that uh we'll we'll
turn to to talk about arya and some of
the questions
around the bill if we may yeah but just
to um to kind of reflect on
uh what we've heard uh so far on science
funding
uh i may be wrong but i get the
impression that um
the discussions are continuing there's a
difficult fiscal settlement
and the fact that they're continuing
suggest to me that you're
you're in uh a series of conversations
and you're advocating
for this um would you would you accept
that given the commitment
that you've reiterated to
a doubling of the science budget and to
an overall investment in r d that is to
reach 2.4 percent by 2027. yeah it would
be
it would be paradoxical and regrettable
if there were to be a shrinkage in
the science budget in the next couple of
years
is that yes i mean look as far as i'm
concerned the secretary of state forbade
uh i want us to honor our commitments
and lead the way
as a science superpower you will
appreciate from your days
as i believe you were financial
secretary to the treasury so you know
what the process is like
there's a huge amount of debate people
will
debate how you define the spending how
you define the r d spending
and that's something which within
government all governments in fact
have always had these discussions
between different departments
but the broad commitment remains uh the
same as a secretary of state
uh i see a key part of my job is to make
sure that we hit those targets
fantastic and then in terms of the of
the short term as well as the the long
term okay can i just um
confirm which i anticipated the case
that you're aware of the
the consequence the thought would be bad
consequences for things like
take the the faraday institution that
was
established to develop cutting-edge
technology
in batteries and we know that's going to
be important uh in the the future
um it's because its funding
is not confirmed then it's going to have
to
start to wind down its activities just
at the point
when we need to expand them so as an
example of something for which
a a delay would be
would have severe consequences are you
are you batting for them yeah of course
i mean i'm completely aware of the risks
the liabilities if you like in terms of
our funding situation
through a number of great projects i
mean you mentioned the faraday uh
challenge the friday institute
uh that's a great project and clearly if
we're we're in a world where we're
cash constrained we're budget
constrained a lot of great projects
may be exposed and our job is to protect
them and make sure that the actual
quantum the the the the rate of change
is where the increase
uh is sufficient to make sure that these
things thrive and grow and that's that's
part of my job
and in the same vein and it's it's it's
not too
too late at your your feet personally
because as you made it very clear
there's a
conversation across government about
this but on the
oda and whether that is uh made up
i mean ukrai have had to this week
um make an announcement that there's a
120 million pounds gap between
allocations and commitments so these are
projects that have already been
passed they've been scrutinized approved
and found to be uh
good value for money and impactful and
ukri government agency or arms length
agency has said
it's unavoidable that some grants will
need to be terminated
that that again can i take it that
you're you're battling to
to avoid that having to be put into
effect that's what sure we're always
um making uh these uh kate's
representing
as passionately and as energetically as
we can
the interests of our science base but
there is a wider context here
uh we're committed uh to trying to
reduce by five billion pounds
uh the odor spend and that will have
consequences but this is in the context
of an unprecedented uh fiscal situation
that you will remember from your
treasury days it wasn't a single time
in those years where we were
spending 407 billion pounds as we have
done
to keep the economy going it means there
were very very difficult choices
i think the prime minister the
government the chancellor have had the
courage to make those choices
but some of them have had impact and i
think in bits of our research
uh spending particularly without the
odor money um
that there have been difficult choices
that have been made and finally before i
turned to graham
stringer on on aria i don't know whether
you heard any of the evidence from
dominic cummings heard it in patches
well he was he was making the case that
um that support from number 10
the center number 10 in the treasury was
very important
to to advance your ambitions and he was
very complimentary about officials
in bays in this regard do you
do you have the same level of
enthusiasm and commitment uh in number
10 perhaps
perhaps this is uh one for joe
and um in terms of your perhaps i could
talk about your
the circumstances of your appointment
was was this something on the prime
minister's mind did he
emphasize the importance of science and
delivery absolutely i mean in terms of
my appointment we can talk about that
i was minister for energy for 18 months
i was not an
unknown quantity within bayes and during
that time
we launched we had the obviously when
you were secretary of state we passed
the
uh uh net zero uh act um and we
had the ten point plan and the energy
white paper and what the prime minister
expressly said to me
uh is that uh bayes you've come within
from within bayes and we need to really
up our game not only on net zero
but we need to think about what we're
doing in terms of innovation and other
areas of the portfolio
i think within the first week that i was
there i
essentially commissioned an innovation
strategy and i'm very delighted that joe
uh is the director general that's
driving that and she's doing a great job
and the officials
as you will remember uh within bayes are
are second to none
across whitehall and it's a very very
good department to be
uh to be secretary of state for as i'm
sure you remember absolutely but joe
would like to maybe confirm yes perhaps
um i don't want to put you in an
invidious position because you
uh you obviously uh have to work with
colleagues across whitehall but um
can i take it that that you are you're
still effectively engaged
uh as a department uh with number 10
even given the personnel changes that
have happened there during your tenure
if not the
secretary of state's as secretary of
state so absolutely the prime minister's
i think personal commitment to science
innovation technology
is completely clear to everyone in
government you see it yesterday and the
launch of the integrated review and
the sort of uh how central science and
technology is
to that and so we continue to work
really closely with number 10 and we
absolutely
feel their support loud and clear for
what we're trying to do in the
department
are you part of these discussions that
dominic cummings mentioned that the
prime minister had approved to create
in the center in the cabinet office a a
strong science
cross-government uh team capability
so the um secretary of state
is the secretary of state for science
and innovation that is very clear
we're always working with our colleagues
across whitehall about how we make sure
we deliver on the
integrated review and the role that the
cabinet office can play in bringing
together all of the bits of government
because in bays we're responsible for
the science system
as you know and particular elements
fusion research
net zero but you know what the mod do
what dhsc do
and all other departments is really
important and the cabinet office have
got a really strong role in bringing it
all together to be
more than the sum of its parts indeed mr
cummings said that because of that
because it spread across
whitehall the prime minister had
commissioned the cabinet secretary to
create this
cabinet office team is that is that
underway is that being created so i'm
not going to speak for the prime
minister and what his
plans are there you know we always look
at how we best make sure we deliver the
prime minister's ambitions and they're
really clear on science and technology
particularly on that i mean i was very
clear with the prime minister that i
wanted bayes to take a lead
in terms of science policy and that's
why i
immediately commissioned the innovation
strategy which joe
is leading that was within my first week
as secretary of state
and also i said explicitly that we would
own the space strategy i mean if you
look at
space and policy around space that was
sitting in lots of different
uh buckets uh number 10 obviously had a
clear
interest in it as did the uk
space agency other departments the mod
and others
and i've said that bayes will really
take the lead on this
and we're holding the pen on the space
strategy and we're very keen
and excited about delivering that uh in
the next few months and i'm sure your
committee will be very interested
in that work great so you're going to be
a muscular
force in promoting and indeed defending
um
the absolute science and related uh
policy and budgets
yeah it'll be it'll be a very energetic
uh approach
that we've played thank you let's go
into a bit more detail
on aria starting with graham stringer
and then aaron bell
morning secretary of state good good to
see you
just a couple of uh questions
in detail on the bill you so you've got
it in front of you absolutely
if you look at clause 2 6 a b
and c and tell the committee
why there isn't a was a section on the
economy
innovation uh improving quality of life
there's nothing specifically on
on defense i mean
you could point to lots of different
it's quite a short bill it's a succinct
bill
and of course as you know from your
parliamentary experience what we didn't
want to have
was uh what is often called a christmas
tree type bill we didn't want
to capture life the universe and
everything on the face of the bill
you will also know given your
governmental experience
and parliamentary experience that the
mod
has a specific interest in defense and
we're not trying
contrary to common belief to recreate
darpa which again as you know
is the u.s uh uh defense uh
sort of research agency arya's something
very different
i'm sure dominic cummings would have
mentioned that uh and he would say that
arya's
inspiration was really the upper uh of
the of the 1960s which wasn't as the
defense focus as as darpa and i think
this is reflected
uh on the face of the bill as you've as
you've mentioned
great
in terms of a really difficult balance
in
accounting for the expenditure of public
money
and giving scientists the freedom uh
to innovate and think the
unthinkable i was slightly disappointed
when i read the bill
because if you reach schedule one yeah
it effectively uh
gives you a secondary state or the
government uh
the ability to completely take control
and even if you don't use it
that is hanging over uh the organization
at any time do you think you've got the
balance right secretary of
uh state in giving the necessary freedom
to this body
i think you're absolutely right that
there is a difficult and delicate
balance to strike
between parliamentary oversight and some
degree of
control which oversight implies and the
intellectual freedom
uh that is so necessary to making a
success of this kind of institution and
dominic cummings
spoke uh very eloquently as i saw about
the the intellectual freedom
the uh invention the creativity that's
required
but as a parliamentarian you will
appreciate and certainly i do as
secretary of state
that this organization does have to have
some degree of parliamentary oversight i
think schedule one which you refer to
and i've referred to in my answers
outlines very clear clauses which allow
the sector of state
to intervene should he or she have to
but also
i think permits the organization with
its non-executive
members of the board and its executive
members of the board and its director to
have a degree of
independence i think there is a good
balance that's been struck in the bill
dominic talked about de-bureaucratizing
science and the sort of
latest most the largest example he gave
was comparing uh they've got the
excellent development of a vaccine
and the distribution of vaccine which is
absolutely
world-class and first-rate with the
procurement of ppe
and the rollout of test and trace and
isolate
have you learned any lessons from the
comparison between those two
projects that you can apply to uh
area or science in general i think we've
learned
we've all learnt a huge amount from the
experience of the last
of the last year uh what i want to use
the opportunity now is to say that the
vaccine rollout was an extraordinary
thing that happened i mean within it if
we just reflect on what happened and i
think we should
um within a year we essentially found
this appalling illness this appalling
virus our scientists managed to
work out how to vaccinate people we we
got the vaccine we produced the vaccine
and we distributed it to the extent of
millions i think today
something like 25 million of our people
have been vaccinated
and all of this happened within 12
months i think it's an extraordinary
story and i think
we can't dwell enough on it in terms of
other areas i think
lessons have been learned and i'm sure
dominic cummings
has expressed himself uh on that i think
uh the prime minister
and people within the government have
talked about you know trying to learn
the lessons that may well be
an inquiry uh that will take place after
we've come out
uh of this process and clearly there's a
lot that we've learned but i think the
vaccine roll out the bit that baze was
involved with and i'm very pleased
and flattered that dominic cummings
acknowledged uh this department's role
in that the the part that we played i
thought was
was exemplary thank you
thank you very much indeed it's on the
vaccine from triumph such as it's been
and
a real fantastic example of
science the nhs government
funding bodies uh working together
clearly something to be
emulated you'll know that jeremy farah
is the director of the
the welcome foundation one of the
principal charitable
funders he's expressed himself
concerned he's he's been part of the
member of sage he's been part of all of
this these discussions
uh he said that as things stand the
national institute for health research
faces a funding cut for global health
funding
obviously crucial to just what we've
been talking about uh of 28
is that something uh this this goes back
to what we were talking about
is that something you've raised with the
prime minister the the imperative of
getting this sorted i have raised with
the prime minister a number of times
the fact that we've got to do we're you
know we've got to do two things
on the one hand we're talking the talk
of science superpower which is great
but fundamentally we also have to walk
and that's and that's something that
i remind the prime minister about
constantly fantastic
thank you thank you
thank you i want to ask you some uh sort
of fairly basic logistics about the
setting up of arya but yeah
if i could briefly before i do that just
touch on your radio 4 comments this
morning about the
cumbrick coal mine in which you said you
were sympathetic to what the climate
change committee said about
negative impression it was possibly
causing obviously climate change is a
global problem which is
why we're having cop 26. surely the
rational and scientific thing to do is
to consider the world ecosystem and
emissions globally
in any decisions we make about this and
can you confirm that that's what you
you're obsessed with i mean all i was
saying in the interview was that
as secretary of state for bays i work
extremely closely
with the committee for climate change
and
my views are very much aligned in most
instances
with theirs you will appreciate that
this is something which is going through
a legal process and i'm not going to get
drawn into the
the the the wise of wherefores or the
particulars of that particular case
but generally as secretary of state for
bayes who's one of whose
key priorities is the net zero uh
priority
which i'm very pleased to say that mr
clark actually
drove through the secretary of state and
we take that very very seriously
and as a consequence of that i am very
much closely aligned
uh with the committee on climate change
i understood but
i think the concern would be that we're
not doing things that
offshore our emissions and in fact
absolutely might increase
increase total global emissions at the
expense of you know making ourselves
look good i think that's true
but also i think one of the things we
announced today and i'm sure you picked
that up in the interview was of course
the decarbonization of industry yeah
and that's uh clearly the prize that we
are focused on
and if we can actually achieve that we
we won't need to be able to we won't
need
a coking coal in the uk because we won't
be using
that technology it's clearly a long way
some way down
the track but that's the ultimate goal
and that's something i think we can
achieve
in 15 years thank you turn into arya
when
do you intend to begin recruiting for
the chair and the ceo of arya
and will you be restricting the pool of
candidates to scientists or are you
prepared to look
beyond scientists we're not restricting
uh the pool of any candidates
and we're going to be starting i think
in the early summer probably april may
that that sort of time
and will the chief exec and the chair be
subject to
pre-appointment hearings presumably by
this committee uh i don't think
uh they will in the first instance uh
because they're not one of the um
institutions on the order in council
which
uh would that would require um but i
think there's no reason why
we can't uh reach an accommodation with
the committee you know once
the institution is up and running thank
you joe do you want to come in
sorry that's exactly right yeah
absolutely there's no there's no
official requirement for them to have
them but i think
because it's new well it's news yeah i
think he would be welcome if yeah
i mean once it's set up then i'm sure we
can we can find a way of accommodating
the committee's insatiable curiosity and
and will arya
exist in shadow form for a period first
uh and when will it
be fully operational what is there a
specific date in 2022 we're looking at
yeah so i think in terms of process this
is how i see it i think we'll try and
we'll launch a campaign that's the
phrase that we use to find a director
i think we will have some
officials as part of aria and then in
terms of the launch of the organization
i imagine
uh that it'll be at some time in 2022
but
you know these dates could shift as we
all know
would there be a shadow phase before
it's launched or is it just i'm not
quite sure what you mean by a shadow
phase
um considering the legislation so we
have no organization until parliament's
considered the legislation
um but our hope and expectation is it's
fully operational in 2022
obviously depending on the timing of the
passage of legislation we will then look
at whether
and the appointment of the chairmanship
exec whether it makes sense to have some
sort of
shadow phase as you say as we did with
ukri
and before we enact the provisions if
parliament passes them
um for arya to be fully constituted it's
obviously vital to get the right person
i know
catherine's going to ask about that just
on that point in terms of the kind of
shadow organization
my understanding and perhaps show you
know better is
that you can establish after second
reading has been passed
a shadow organization that is sure um so
you can get underway
rather than waiting for the the length
of the parliamentary
process is that the intention to make
use of that
uh ability i think what we want to do
first the secretary of state says make
sure we have identified
the right chair the right um chief
executive for this organization that is
the priority
alongside the passenger legislation
we've got to jump the fences as they
come
so you get on with that yes so once
we've identified and hired and you know
signed the deal as it were on a director
then
the other elements can fall into place
and we can deal with
with those with those problems as they
arise thank you i mean
as the committee's report rightly says
you know the culture of the organization
the organization structure is key
you know we need the chair and the chief
executive um to be
directing that setting that i don't
think it makes sense for us to get too
far ahead until we've
found those individuals who are going to
shape this organization
thank you
the person is so important all the
people at the very top
and we wouldn't want to be in a
situation where we lose out and miss out
on germany because of
the process and the order that takes
place uh i think my time's nearly up and
i think catherine
fletcher is going to follow up on all
right thank you very much
congratulations
thank you thank you aaron listen when we
were talking to
dominic cummings earlier i was really
keen to kind of understand
how we don't make this impossible for
any normal human being to do the job
you know the the likes the people that
can
spread a breadth from quantum mechanics
to
net zero technologies to the completely
brand new that frankly nobody in this
room is qualified to understand
that's a hell of an individual what
qualities do you want the
aria leadership to have apart from being
super bad or superwoman no i think the
whole superman and superwoman thing
is is a red herring i mean obviously we
want someone who's got the
uh the drive uh and the curiosity
and also actual organizational ability
because it will be a very
uh unusual organization and i can tell
you uh catherine i think
we've already had a lot of interest in
aria not just
from countries who wish to reproduce it
and are very interested in what we're
doing but also from
uh individuals as i understand who are
very interested
in the potential uh you know for
actually
heading and leading an organization
that's so innovative and unusual
i think there's a huge amount of
interest i'm very confident that we will
at the end of the campaign hire someone
with the requisite
skills i think as i say a passion for
innovation
flexibility of mind energy all of these
qualities
they don't have to know everything about
everything but i'm sure we can find
someone who has the requisite skills to
to drive the project forward and
to culture because you mentioned
leadership and ultimately any system
that's relying on people it's about
culture and leadership
at the end of it and are you going to
hire someone that is going to create a
skunk
works off the wall collaborative culture
or are you looking for someone that is
capable of effectively administering
others to do that
in the in the ceo chair roles um i think
there's no reason why
uh people can't do a bit of both i mean
there are lots of
uh examples i mean i've been very lucky
in my current role
um in this job to speak to people like
demystifies
uh and he's a great innovator he's
someone who uh essentially
headed up deep mind and he's someone who
has got
people skills he has got uh leadership
qualities but also he's
an innovative and creative uh thinker
there are lots of people
out there who really have an appetite uh
to do this
uh kind of work and i'm very hopeful
that we can recruit
uh someone in that in that mold
very enough thank you secretary of state
thank you chair thank you
thank you very much indeed did you do
anything to that
just to say obviously i mean it's a
great question we're making different
appointments here so we're appointing
the chair and we'll be appointing the
non-executives in future
and then we appoint the first ceo we'll
want different skills in those people
particularly the chief executive and the
chair and one of the balances we've
tried to strike
in the legislation and schedule one
which we've talked about is as well as
giving after the operational
freedom it absolutely needs it's sort of
good governance that there is a board
with the majority of non-execs
um accounts an annual report which will
be laid before parliament
um and so therefore the skills of the
person to lead the board
will be different to the skills of the
chief executive who's going to you know
really drive and create the culture
and identify and lead the programme
managers which is where the sort of
domain specific expertise will really
be vital i'm sorry just one very
follow-up
and what dominic cummings was talking
about was if it gets too close to
conventional structures it's going to
fail
and just in listening to that with
non-execs and permanent roles
that sounds quite like existing cultures
we heard lots from
us darpa about the fact that everybody
has a temporary
is temporary they have an end date on
their passes
to make sure that they don't get too
comfortable is that going to be part of
this
so catherine you've identified the key
problem that we've been talking about
we've got a balance on the one hand
something that's new
and innovative and creative and slightly
wacky perhaps and unconventional
but on the other hand we've got to have
corporate governance and you know i have
to i'm responsible to
you know people like you frankly in
parliament as i should be
uh to justify the the actions of this
of this uh project of this uh
organization so
we do have to have corporate governance
structures which are very clearly
outlined in schedule one of the bill um
but at the same time
we want to create something that's new
and fresh and innovative so it's a
balance
that i think graham stringer uh referred
to i think the balance is about right
but clearly if i don't get it right i
will be up here uh answering questions
uh in front of mr clark and yourselves
thank you very much just a a a couple of
final ones
obviously one of the big questions in
our report and uh
and in what we've heard today and in the
commentary since the bill was published
was what the focus is going to be yeah
do you
take us into your confidence uh on that
what are your tips on
that look i think that's a very fair
question i mean if i were in your
position i would say
i would be asking so what are the core
missions of avari i think that's a
legitimate question
i think the point that dominic cummings
made or i'm sure would have made
is that you know that will be a job for
the people who we hire who are running
the organization
but just to give you a flavor um i'm
very keen that we have an innovation
strategy
in that innovation strategy it'll be
coming uh follow up from your grand
challenges i'm sure we'll be refining
those
that will provide what i call tram lines
now it'll be up to
the head of arpa uh to decide whether he
or she thinks the organization should
adopt what the innovation strategy
suggests or
adapt it or reject it that'll they will
have independence yeah
but i think there is a role for
government to uh stress
uh or outline tram lines as i call them
uh
in terms of where the uk where we think
the uk has a comparative advantage
and what areas uh we want to see you
know dynamic innovation in
so you'll publish the innovation
strategy and the the
personal people running upper will
consider that
and then it's up to them to decide i
think ultimately it will it will it will
be up to them but that's something which
um you know i look forward to to having
that conversation
when it's up and running and and finally
you've probably heard some of the
reflections partly to do with the the
needs
for aria being a reflection on the the
levels of bureaucracy
and delay in the current
research structure now you you've
inherited this i mean
what are your first impressions does it
conform to what um dominic coming in no
i mean dominic has his own uh particular
take on things
i don't see ukrai as something which has
been
you know mired in bureaucracy and red
tape i think that
uh for what it is and what it does it's
very effective but the way i look at it
is that arya and
ukri are trying to do different things
so you can't judge them on the same
criteria they're different beasts if you
like
and what i would say is the ukri i think
does work effectively
i think as the main sort of channel of
science and research funding in the uk
particularly in academia it works very
well but one of the things that i've
learned
in my brief time with sexual states
talking to people like stephen chu
nobel prize winning laureates uh and
really amazing researchers and brilliant
researchers is that we need to have a
diversity
you know all the best uh researchers all
the most innovative thinkers in this
space
will say you have to have a diversity of
institutions as they do in the united
states
and i think arya does give us uh always
a step towards
a greater diversity in terms of our
approach to r d the concern might be and
the committees you know
endorse the the proposal but the concern
might be that that
is thought to kind of satisfy the the
appetite for reform
when the the great majority over 95
percent
i think 98 of science funding will be
through other
organizations and even in ukraine
people who've given evidence to the
committee from
ukri and including people who've led
ukraine in the past have been very
critical about
some of the bureaucracy that they feel
that they that is imposed
on them so do you have a reform agenda
yeah i mean as joe mentioned
um earlier in her um excellent uh
answers
uh we are actually going down a review
of bureaucracy precisely
uh to try and uh you know cut away some
of the red tape
uh that people have complained about all
i was trying to say is that i think ukri
does a good job
i don't see it as the bureaucratic
nightmare that
others have portrayed i think it has
been effective you just need to look at
as i said the vaccine rollout but
that doesn't mean that bureaucracy isn't
a problem it doesn't mean that we you
know it's
utterly perfect and it doesn't mean that
we can't do more
to try and and tackle bureaucracy i mean
joe do you want to come in on the
review uh yes so as we said we'll be um
launching the review announced in the r
d roadmap to look at the whole system
because it is not just ukri's role or
other research funding agencies it's how
it interacts with what goes on in
higher education institutes and other
sort of places that research happen
i think the other thing i'd um observe
is ukraine is still a really young
organization and
ottole eliza and i were giving evidence
to the public accounts committee a
couple of weeks ago about the industrial
strategy challenge fund
and exploring their you know how ukri is
developing in its capability to
um to business cases and set out the
monitoring and evaluation of projects
so that we all rightly can you see you
know evaluate the impact of the research
that they fund and therefore the public
money that we're putting into it so as
ukrai
matures as an organization you know so
so this all works more smoothly as well
and would you expect to conclude that
that review of um bureaucracy i think it
will um
we're expecting it to conclude at the
start of next year you know these are
system-wide issues we want to look at
them deeply and thoroughly it's a sort
of
generational reform we hope to take
through um as a result of looking at the
issues
excellent well that i think concludes
our
questions uh today thank you very much
indeed thank you very much
for your time um we we've gained a lot
of insights that will help
i hope parliament and both houses of
parliament scrutinize the arya bill
uh when it goes in on the floor of the
house and into committee
you've addressed some of the the very
live and urgent
questions of science funding and we've
got a clear view
as to your muscular intention uh on that
uh we we wish you well and we hope that
you will be able to come back to the
committee very
soon with some positive news in
particular in the context of a
rising very welcome rising science
budget that it would be
totally counterproductive to find any
shrinkage in that
in the shorter term thank you very much
today and thank you for your first
appearance
uh in your in europe thank you so that
concludes our hearing
order order thank you
the proceeding has ended
the proceeding has ended